HECHT: My name is Bill
Hecht, for the one or two
of you in the audience who are
young enough not to know me.
I started this job many years
ago as a younger alumnus
and I've now become
an older alumnus.
And it has nothing
to do with the job,
it has to do with this natural
process we all go through.
Welcome back to Technology Day.
For those of you who are my
contemporaries or a bit older,
this is Saturday morning class.
For you young people,
when they softened up MIT,
they don't have Saturday
morning class anymore.
But we were all
accustomed to it.
And in the thing we call the
real world, which is not MIT,
there is always
Saturday morning class.
My job is to welcome you all,
to get you in your chairs,
and to introduce the man who is
a gift to us, the second gift
to us from the
University of Michigan.
We had a great president given
to us many years ago named
Jerry Wiesner from the
University of Michigan.
And lightning struck
again a number of years
ago when Chuck Vest joined us.
Without any further ado,
Chuck Vest, president of MIT.
VEST: Thank you very much, Bill.
Good morning and welcome
home to all of you.
Before we begin the
excursion into what
I think of as serious
fun this morning,
I do have a somewhat
more serious announcement
that I have been asked
to make by the registrar.
He informed me this morning
that due to some sort
of an archival error,
the registrar no longer
has documentary evidence
that certain MIT
graduates successfully
completed their swimming tests.
These graduates are therefore
required to retake the swimming
test immediately.
Failure to comply
with this will result
in revocation of your degrees.
As far as we can
tell, the lost records
are those belonging
to all graduates
of the classes of 1957, '62,
'67, '72, '77, '82, and '87.
So you're asked to report over
to the alumni pool immediately.
Staff are there prepared
to administer the test,
and we hope you can hurry
back before the end of today's
program.
Good luck to all of you.
Now, where was I?
Today, as I said, it
really is a real pleasure
to welcome all of you back
home to the MIT campus.
And we are indeed
going to engage
in something that goes on
around here all the time, which
we call serious fun.
This is a place of serious
work, of serious purpose,
but also of serious
humor and serious fun.
And I'm sure that's
something that
hasn't changed since the days
you were here as students.
There's always been a complex
intermingling of fun--
excuse me, of work and
of play here at MIT.
One reason for
this is, of course,
that the heart of the Institute,
namely its student body,
remains forever young.
Some people say that staying on
the faculty at an institution
like this is a little bit like
living in the funny papers.
Nobody's age ever
seems to change.
And that's something
we value deeply.
But of course, young people
prefer to blend pleasure
together with their labor.
And actually, it's my
observation that most of you
continue to do that as well.
Now, the reason that the
brilliance of this community
is often and fortunately paired
with a vigorous if sometimes
warped sense of humor and
fun is pretty obvious.
There are lots of
scholarly writings
on the analogies between humor
and scientific discovery.
These things are all
quite well known.
Both humor and
scientific discovery
very frequently have in common
the sudden merging of two
seemingly very disparate ideas.
This conjugation
is something that I
think we all have
the good fortune
to experience from time to time.
So it really is no surprise
that humor and sports and games
and other diversions
are prominent features
of the Institute's landscape.
Another reason, I suppose, is
that this is an extraordinarily
competitive community.
And the desire to excel
infects our play every bit
as much as it does our work.
And finally, the last reason
I might cite that play
is important to us,
and it goes right
to the heart of something
that's very valuable in an MIT
education.
Because this is a
research university
and because Paul Gray and so
many others on our faculty
and staff over the years have
helped to really integrate
our undergraduates into
their research programs,
it's fair to say that one of
the favorite catch phrases
around the Institute
a little bit
in parallel to our
traditional learning by doing
might also be
learning by playing.
And that of course, is a
very familiar phenomenon
to all of us.
Connections between
creativity and playfulness,
between intellectual
acuity and physical vigor,
between mental agility
and bodily agility
are well established.
Now, that's what
I was told to say,
but as I was thinking
about it this morning,
I came up with a
few counterexamples
to that statement that I
think I can cite as well.
But on the whole, it's correct.
It's for this very reason
that we invest so heavily
in facilities and programs
for both physical and mental
recreation.
And it's also why our students
and our faculty and our staff
invest so much of
their time and energy
in these vital, rewarding,
and stimulating pursuits.
Let me expand on this
just for a moment
by saying a couple of words
about MIT's athletic programs.
Among American
universities, MIT ranks
a close second to
the number of varsity
teams at fields for
intercollegiate competition.
Harvard beats us, we
understand, by two squads.
We field about 39
and they have 41.
This is a truly
extraordinary number
if you stop to think about it.
By the time they
graduate, around a quarter
of our MIT students have
participated in varsity sports,
often reaping the
rewards that come
from teamwork, from
training, from challenge,
and from competition.
In fact, one of the
anecdotes that I tell people
that I come across around the
country and world who really
don't know a lot about
MIT, which to me explained
a lot of our spirit when I first
came here is the following.
Becky and I follow a tradition
that Paul and Priscilla started
of hosting our seniors for
dinner in a series of eight
or nine evenings at the
president's house in February.
My first year here, I
was sitting at the table
next to a very petite
young woman who
was graduating in physics.
And I asked her what she
was interested in doing
in addition to physics.
And she told me that she played
women's varsity ice hockey.
And I said, well,
that's really terrific.
And trying to make
a little small talk,
I said, did you play ice
hockey in high school?
And she looked at me very
seriously and she said,
President Vest, I
couldn't even skate
when I was in high school.
And this year, another senior
stood up, also a young woman
in this evening.
And she said, you
know, the thing
that I have valued most about
MIT is the number of firsts.
And what I mean by that
is the number of things
I did for the first
time when I came here.
And I think that's a
lot of the spirit that
infuses all of our
activities in athletics,
in theater, in
music, and so forth.
Very often young
people trying out
and exploring things
for the first time
and flowering in ways that no
one would ever have predicted.
So we think a lot
about the importance
of intercollegiate
sports and clubs sports
and recreation here
at the Institute.
In addition, of
course, there are,
as I said, intramural and
club activities of all kinds.
The workout rooms, the swimming
pool, the tennis courts,
the squash courts,
the basketball courts,
the playing fields, and
all the other facilities
that MIT students
have at their disposal
are very important
elements to the campus.
And of course, beyond
athletics, there
are countless other
opportunities for our students
to learn by playing, literally.
In music, in theater,
in dance, in art.
And of course, what
begins as play,
and that was really the meaning
of my couple of anecdotes
a moment ago, what often
begins as play ends up
in deep intellectual
and artistic exploration
and creativity.
And if all this
weren't enough, we
offer another
resource that provides
considerable opportunity
for ingenious play.
Our students have
virtually unlimited access
to the use of the internet.
At MIT, the use of computers
and the World Wide Web,
which of course we
manage here, are not only
essential tools of
education, they also
provide whole worlds of
recreational opportunities.
And every now and then, some
of these are even constructive.
Given the enthusiasm with
which MIT students, faculty,
and staff alike have embraced
the internet and the World Wide
Web as a tool for
both work and play,
it's no wonder that
just a few weeks ago, we
were ranked number
one most wired
college or university
in the United States
by Yahoo, the internet
life online magazine.
We're still not sure
exactly what this means,
but we love things that say
we're number one so we're
going to accept it.
In all these ways and
in a good many more,
work and play are
in fact intertwined
in the pursuit of knowledge
here at the Institute.
It's a tradition of
which we are proud
and for which I believe we will
continue to write new chapters.
And I think that will give
you a little sense of what
this morning and the day are
really going to be all about.
Now, we're going to
continue this morning
in a pretty informal manner.
We're not going to have a lot
of very lengthy introductions.
In a moment, I will introduce
our very first speaker
of the morning and he will
be followed in succession
by three others.
Seymour Papert of the MIT
Media Lab, who I think
is known to many of you as the
originator of the logo program.
Someone who has devoted
a career to merging
the cognitive
sciences and computing
technology with a
particular emphasis
on learning,
particularly by children.
Seymour will be
followed by Ed Crawley,
the head of our Department of
Aeronautics and Astronautics.
A person who conducts
a lot of his play
time a few thousand feet
in the air with no motor.
And I don't know, Ed, if
you're going to say anything
about that today,
but Ed is indeed
a glider pilot, soaring
pilot, and I think
has been just a
terrific driving force
sort of bringing in the new
generation of engineering
education at MIT, as has
the speaker who follows him,
Woody Flowers, who
if anyone can say
that the following speaker
needs no introduction,
it surely has to be Woody.
So I'm not going to say
anything more about Woody.
Our first speaker,
I think, is going
to be a real treat for
all of us, Steve Jacobsen.
Steve received his
doctorate degree here
in the mechanical engineering
department in 1973.
Today he is a professor
of mechanical engineering
at the University of Utah.
But also holds appointments
there in both computer science,
in bioengineering, and in
the department of surgery
in their medical school.
Steve directs the
University of Utah Center
for Engineering Design,
which has collaborated
with a number of
corporate partners
in creating several
of today's most
exciting and advanced
applications of engineering
technology.
His career as a teacher and
a technological innovator
offers ample proof that
engineering of course
can be useful, but it also
can be fun and fascinating
all at the same time.
Steve.
JACOBSEN: Hello?
Oh, here we go.
Good.
Well, it's great to be here.
I, as President Vest
said, left here in 1973.
And I was actually an
office-mate of Woody.
So I go back a long time.
Also as a student of Bob Mann,
who I see is in the audience.
One thought I had when
we were discussing--
or President Vest was
discussing athletics
was that this morning
I couldn't find anybody
who knew that the Jazz won.
They'd say, what's a jazz?
And the Jazz are
in a death struggle
here with Michael Jordan, if
anybody follows basketball.
Yeah?
OK, I'll stand to this side.
And so it was important
to me to find out.
Actually, what I
thought about, too,
was a lecture I got once
about MIT and athletics,
which I thought was
really important.
And that was that the
purpose of athletics at MIT--
this was my own conclusion--
was for participation, not
observation.
Whereas spectator sports are
great things, the idea at MIT
was to give an
opportunity for people
to get involved in
every kind of sport.
And I happen to agree that
that's probably the best
way for a university to behave.
As a little background so
I can explain my biases,
and I have to go over and get
the clicker here, or the laser
printer.
I've kind of got a
weird background.
I went back to Utah
actually because they'd
give me some freedoms that I
couldn't get at other places.
And that was to do some things
directly and very tightly
with industry.
And so I started a
place called the Center
for Engineering Design.
And then at one
point, we founded
a company called
Sarcos, and we were all
interested in doing design.
And I'll talk about that a
little bit more in a second.
But we were interested in
turning ideas into things,
but I mean, like really.
Not just talk about it.
And we now grew to
about 150 people,
and we have about 20 associates
and an average of about
13 adult graduate students.
By adults, we mean
that they fully
know where they want to go,
and that they have experience,
and they come from a lot
of different fields--
there's a spider there--
from engineering to
science to medicine
to art, business,
and manufacturing.
And in fact, I guess
now we have in the group
about 15 sculptors that are
quite good at what they do.
And we do projects for
commercial, government,
and internal sponsors.
And we usually have
about 30 projects
going on, ranging from building
robotic butterflies for Steve
Wynn for his new hotel
Bellagio, to doing things
that I'll classify, since we're
talking about fun, as deep fun.
Now there's fun fun,
and there's hard fun,
and then there's deep fun.
And deep fun is where
there's more pain
than there is pleasure.
[LAUGHTER]
And sometimes at the
end there's ecstasy.
But for sure, one thing
is true-- you're always
in a position
where you can lose.
And because we
take projects that
are basically fixed-budget
and fixed-schedule,
and we embed the R&D
kinds of activities
we want to do in those projects,
and it's a grueling thing,
but it's something we believe
in because it keeps you
from dallying in the valley.
We do commercial
design, not designology,
and we believe in all
methods of design--
CAD/CAM, for sure, and then
one that I use to talk about,
which is called Pod-POM.
And Pod-POM is plain old design
and plain old manufacturing,
where you think, and I have
a personal bias for computers
and against computers.
The thing for is they
are facilitators,
but the thing that's bad
about them is too many times,
you believe them.
And so something that comes
out of a computer to us
is just a prototype.
It's not gospel.
We get involved in a
lot of different areas,
and I have a reason
for talking about this.
But you can't read all
these, and Bob Mann
will give me trouble for
having too much on my slide.
But we get involved in
medicine, entertainment,
human interactive
systems and microsystems.
And that means micro-catheters
to go in your brain,
and we're actually
commercializing that now;
programmable drug
delivery systems that
we're commercializing for
things like controlling clots
or cancer or whatever;
some diabetic catheters;
artificial limbs--
the artificial limbs
project started here;
entertainment of all
sorts, a lot of casinos,
Disney, Jurassic Park,
Universal, and so on;
robots to go under the sea.
And since all of these things
need sensors and computers
and actuators, we do a lot
of work in micro-systems,
and that is using
modern technologies
from miniaturization to
build interesting systems.
And also, you'll see
as I discuss things,
and this is sort of a
plea to schools to not
have areas so nicely defined.
One nice thing about MIT
was they didn't really
see departments as the
only place you could work.
And so Utah got involved
in a lot of places,
and I just want to announce
that since I've also
got a position in surgery,
I do cheap surgery.
So if anybody's got any
problems, see me after.
But we get involved in
machines that take information
to control them, and that
sounds like a trite term,
and it's a horrible statement.
But it means machines
that basically
use sensors, actuators,
controllers, structures,
and conduits that have high
levels of interdependence.
And you'll see when you see the
robots that there's sensors,
actuators, structures,
controllers,
and so on that
all work together,
and if anyone little
part doesn't work,
then they don't work.
So they are nightmares.
The Disney robots we built
had up to 50 actuators
and 100 sensors
in a single robot,
and you can see when one
of them doesn't work.
When we did the project
for European Disneyland,
it was 9,000 sensors,
4,000 actuators,
all sorts of computers
and structures, and so on,
and rubber faces, and
clothing, and so on.
And so it all had to work.
We also believe in design
tools using computers.
And again, you can't
live without them,
but you can die with
too many of them.
So today we were going to
talk about technology at play,
and you can interpret that
a lot of different ways.
And we talked in the title
about sports, games, and toys,
and we've been
involved in some toys.
I didn't bring one up with
me, but some Mickey Mouse
watches and some little shooter
systems and so on that actually
are quite technical devices.
But they are toys.
But we sort of led
away and got involved
in some other areas,
which are theme parks
and casinos and location-based
entertainment and exhibitions
and shows, and we've had
some rather sizable projects
in those areas.
And just so we
don't go to sleep,
I thought I'd show you just a
short clip on tape number three
of this fellow.
This is one of the sculpts
for Jurassic Park, the ride.
And he's in clay,
and I'll show you
how we come about having those.
But he's really
wonderful, isn't he?
He's so big and fully packed.
Why don't you show
tape three, please?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --are present in this area.
JACOBSEN: This is going on
the ride, and this is T-Rex 1.
We've got to turn up the sound.
Yeah, there we go.
And this is T-Rex 2.
[ROARING]
[SCREAMS]
We'll see another shot.
This is coming out of the bottom
at about 60 miles an hour.
And now you'll see a
side view of this robot.
[ROARING]
And you'll see some people
in a second moving around
to show you the size.
You can turn that off now.
Just put it on pause.
[END PLAYBACK]
And we'll get back to
that kind of thing,
but just to give you
a little preview,
those are really
not unserious fun.
He's 80,000 pounds.
He's above the
clients, or the guests,
and he comes out over them, and
so he has to work all the time,
and he has to be
dynamic and so on.
So the process of achieving
him was not straightforward.
So one thing people
ask us when they--
by the way, when they
see the list of all the
projects we work on, the venture
capitalists say, you're crazy.
And other people
say you're crazy.
Your wife certainly
says you're crazy.
But we're sort of
addicts in the place,
and you have a lot
of them around here.
I tell people
usually MIT is sort
of full of addicts of various
kinds addicted to their work.
But we actually talked
about it in our group
of maybe the 50 central
people and says,
why do we keep taking
these projects?
The last one that
came to us, they
wanted us to do Godzilla, a
giant new kind of Godzilla,
not a big furry bear.
And we actually
turned them down.
It was amazing.
But we decided we love
machines-- not more
than our families, but the
whole process of scheming
it takes to define a new
machine and the teamwork
necessary to build
competitive systems,
and I emphasize competitive,
because the things we do
are competitive, and they're
economically competitive,
understanding the technologies
and the manufacturing
methods required to make them.
If you take a look
at the T-Rex there's
every kind of computer
process to analyze them.
There's fiberglass and
rubber and clay systems
and foam systems, all
sorts of different parts,
and these have to run, as I'll
talk, in terrible environments.
The educational processes
necessary to create a team that
can compete in the real
marketplace and especially
in the entertainment marketplace
is sort of like hamburger.
It just sort of
churns people up.
One of the jokes is that the
companies keep going bankrupt,
and the people just moved
to different companies,
so the company names change,
but the people never change.
They just move to a
different company.
We like the participants,
the students,
and I don't just
mean young students.
Anybody who does this has to be
an old student if they're old.
And the competition is fun.
It's great to win, and it's
great to have the motivation
to win.
Another thing we like
regarding machines
which isn't talked about a lot
is the people aspects of them.
And both Woody and I collect
a bunch of old things,
and we look at them maybe
different than other people.
I always look at them, and I
wonder about their relationship
with people.
Who are the users?
And who needed the machine?
And who was the manufacturer,
and what were their biases?
What was the technology that was
available in terms of material
knowledge and tools?
Who paid the bill,
and why they did it?
And what was the price?
And why did they pick
a particular look?
I was thinking--
I was mentioning
to Woody about
Harley-Davidson motorcycles.
They're clearly not
motorcycles, but I
said they're sort of a
rolling American trophy, which
is wonderful, too, and it's
perfectly great to have them.
But if you do start thinking
about machines in those ways,
I think you understand that
we're not any smarter now
than we were there and then, and
they were as smart as we are.
And what you do is you work
with the tools you have.
Scientists have a
certain role, which
has to do with discovering
nature, issues in nature,
and also finding a
discovery suitable
for their tombstone,
some immortal result.
And engineers take
that information
and refine it for use.
And designers, though, just
try to do the best they can
at the time with
the tools they have
and with the things they have.
And so it's a little
bit different field.
Well, how we began doing
this kind of thing--
how did we get in
entertainment--
was an evolution.
And it started actually
with the Utah Arm,
which actually came from MIT.
And we built this arm
based on some control
strategies developed
here, and it's
been a very successful arm.
It's an electromyographic arm
that you put on your body,
and it picks up the signals, and
it's controlled automatically
by the flexion of
remnant muscles.
We then did another
project with MIT's AI lab
called the Utah
MIT Dexterous Hand,
and this is a hand that
has three fingers, just
like Mickey, and a
thumb and a master.
And this hand will do anything
this master tells it to do
or that a computer
tells it to do.
And it was an interesting
study, and that got us
into building systems undersea.
And this is the best
tele-operator in the world.
This can go to the
bottom of the ocean,
and this person can stay
up safely on the boat
and operate this
device in such a way
that there's interaction
with both position and force.
So anything this robot
under the sea feels,
this person perceives
as a load on their arm,
and you can do very complex
manipulation that way.
Well, the reason I showed those
is that somebody at Disney
named Mark Fuller, who now
has a little company that
makes fountains,
saw that, and they
were having a lot of trouble
with Abraham Lincoln, who
you'll see in a second, because
his hands kept flying off,
and he would break and
have all sorts of troubles.
And they asked us to come and
see if we could do something
because we made pretty
hands, the arms,
and we made rugged
robots, and that's
the two properties they wanted.
They wanted to have
graceful motion,
and they also wanted to have
a very robust operation.
So we started into building
anthropomorphic robots,
and this is sort of
like a Disney robot,
but this is one that's at
Carnegie Science Museum,
and it tells kids about
science and technology.
We have another one
we built for Ford
that travels around the world
talking about Ford cars.
But before I show a little
tape on those robots, one
consideration, too, is
when we would do this,
people would say,
oh, this is crazy.
There's no money in this.
I don't know where it's going.
It's too complex, and so on.
But actually, we
found out that if you
want to be in this
field, and if some of you
are students or the
parents of students,
there's some rather
startling economics,
and they're growing
rapidly, as I guess
we have less more and more fun.
But I got these numbers,
and I won't stand
behind any of these numbers.
I got it from our
marketing group,
but numbers for some of these
designations-- theme parks,
5 billion; arcades and
video games, 4 billion;
family fun centers, 4 billion.
We don't do bowling,
spectator sports, box office,
or live entertainment,
but the numbers
get to be good enough
to do something in.
The artificial arm
market is not very large,
and people say, why
did you do that?
And we say, because
we wanted to.
And that's about
all you can say.
But in entertainment,
there's money available.
If you take a look at themed
environments, theme parks,
there are major Tier 1 parks.
Tier 2 and 3 parks--
there's over 200 Tier 2
parks and over 1,000 Tier 3.
And of the major theme parks--
I think this adds up
to 43 or something--
but Disney has four, MCA
Universal three, Cedar Fair
four, Paramount 10, Six Flags
10, Bush 11, and Premier 10.
And there are other
entertainment opportunities
going on that are
absolutely enormous.
If you take a look at
Bellagio Hotel in Las Vegas,
it's now going to
be $1.6 billion.
Japan is putting
in a place together
with Lotte that's $2
billion, and the things that
go in them that we get
involved with look like this.
And this is just the
United States right here,
but coasters now are
running pretty big amounts.
If you see a big roller
coaster, it's $1.5 million.
If you see some
people movers, 1.2.
If you see a lot of rides,
it ends up being 1.7--
strange kinds of rides
like water rides and so on.
So just in the little
attractions that go in parks,
there's a fairly sizable number.
So it is a field is one
thing I'd point out,
and it's growing.
And I don't know why, but people
want to go have fun together,
or they want to be voyeurs
or have riskless risk.
I think riskless
risk is a big thing.
People like to
get into something
that makes it seem
like they're at risk,
but they're all strapped in.
Escapism, dating, distraction--
whatever it is, it's growing.
And another thing that's
happening, in a sense,
we're saying for somebody
who works in this field
is it's changing.
When certain of
the big companies
controlled everything, there
was almost no more brutal place
you could go as a vendor--
no more better
place to be abused.
But things are changing.
The field is growing
15% to 25% a year,
and it's actually
more than that.
Las Vegas hit 30 million guests
last year, which is amazing.
I have a very small number of
people there in comparison.
The attraction prices, as I
mentioned, are increasing.
More parks are being
built. Just like I said,
one little park-- $2 billion.
A broader client base is
weakening central control.
So now, actually,
as a result of that,
producers can get a
piece of the gate.
If you see things like Sky
Fun, which is that big arch,
and you get on this cable,
and they pull you up 200 feet
and let you go--
and not my wife, though.
Not a lot of people Has anybody
seen those in theme parks?
They let you go, and you swing?
It's pretty amazing.
Those are a lot of money, and
people pay $25 for the ride.
So in addition to
getting into the park,
you've got to give them
$25, and they swing you,
and you are
adrenaline-depleted after that.
I don't know what it does,
but it disturbs you a lot.
But you can get a
piece of the gate,
and actually now it's
becoming a technical game,
and this is important to say.
Patents actually work.
Before, it was just sort
of the little old game
that you can hit
these little gophers,
and they go down a hole.
But if you look at
what's happening now,
it's getting very technical,
and also, some people
say these markets are less
susceptible to recession,
but I don't know if that's true.
So I thought I'd give you,
before I talked again,
a little bit about
Jurassic Park.
I'll show you
another little tape.
It's tape number two,
if they're listening
in there, that
shows an evolution
of anthropomorphic
robots we've built.
And let's see if
it will come on.
But it's a fun tape.
It ends up with one of our
robots with Larry King Live.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Oh, you've got to turn it up.
[MUSIC PLAYING - THE TEMPTATIONS
- "AIN'T TOO PROUD TO BEG"]
(SINGING) I don't mind because
you mean that much to me.
Ain't too proud to beg.
JACOBSEN: So this is
how they're controlled,
or they're controlled
automatically,
but this is really nice.
The fellow that's
controlling him
is a mechanical
engineer makeup artist,
which is a strange combination.
He actually did the makeup
for Edward Scissorhands.
Now you can see that the
master system can control
a virtual image as well as a--
we did these about
four years ago.
[ROARING]
A virtual image, as
well as a real one.
This is the Fort
Benning Database
for SEMNET with a wolf in it.
[HOWLING]
Now this is the first--
- Now comes the new Disney
MGM studios theme park.
JACOBSEN: --fielded
robot for Disney.
This is the witch right there.
- It was an accident!
- Well, my little pretty.
I can cause accidents, too.
- Oh, right.
You have no [INAUDIBLE].
- Very well.
I'll bide my time.
But just try to stay out of way.
First try-- I'll
get you, my pretty.
And your little dog, too.
[MANIACAL LAUGHTER]
JACOBSEN: This one has 50
actuators and 100 sensors.
It's an interesting one.
He has a backup group,
you can see there.
And they'll work 24
hours a day, no break.
We also did the insides
of part of King Kong
because he was having trouble--
arthritis.
[ROARING]
- And now you binge rats.
Do I hear six?
Who makes it six?
I'm not sponging for rum.
It be gold I'm after.
- Our defense is
in the preservation
of the spirit which
prizes liberty
as the heritage of all men,
in all lands, everywhere.
- This is CNN.
- We're at the International
Auto Show in Detroit.
It opens tomorrow,
and as we break,
we're going to show you the Ford
computer, this robot, Sarcos.
Let's go now see Sarcos.
- This is Sarcos, the robot
from the Ford exhibit.
May the Ford be with you.
- May the Ford be with you.
Yes.
- Don't forget to listen to
Larry King Live every day
on CNN.
- Good talk, Sarcos.
- That was good.
That was very good.
But you know, I wouldn't
give up your day job.
Is everybody taking off tonight?
Because they're all
wearing the same suit.
Wow, it's such a
pleasure to meet you.
I'll be back.
Hasta la vista, baby.
[MUSIC PLAYING - MARVIN
GAYE, "HEARD IT THROUGH THE
GRAPEVINE"]
(SINGING) I bet you're wondering
how I knew about your plans
to make me blue
with some other guys
we knew before
between the two of us
guys you know I loved you more.
It took me by surprise.
JACOBSEN: It's amazing
how many people
would stay for 20 or 30
minutes and talk to the robot.
But actually they were
talking to a New York stand-up
comedian, Tommy Cohen, who was
at least 60% of the value here.
He's really a great
guy, and you'll
see him in a second describe
how they he operated the system.
- I would like to take to our
viewers behind the scenes--
yes, to see how you actually
work, where all these wires go,
and how you are
managing to look so--
excuse the term-- human.
- Human?
There's no need to insult me.
- This is the secret passage.
- I also do stand-up comedy.
We are the human animators
of the living robot.
I have a camera that is
fixed into my headpiece,
and I can see through there what
Sarcos sees through his eyes.
I also have a
television monitor which
can show me what's
happening in the room,
and I also can see
through the window
here in case I need an
overview of the entire room.
It's actually a lot of fun.
- This operator is a
very talented individual,
and he has become
Sarcos the robot
by virtue of this sensor suit.
The helmet, obviously,
is attached to his head,
so wherever his head
moves, the sensors
mill it and translate
that information
to the computers that drive
the mechanical Sarcos figure.
That's also true for the
shoulders, the elbows,
and the wrists.
Each individual finger
has a positioning sensor
so that it, again, knows
and instructs the computer
as to what moves are required.
Sarcos himself is a
very elaborate hydraulic
and pneumatic mechanism
with other sensors
that provide feedback
back to the computer,
so he literally knows where
he is at any point in time.
- I auditioned for this
job with many other
JACOBSEN: So if we could
turn that off, please.
[END PLAYBACK]
It's funny, but those
were interesting machines.
[APPLAUSE]
So we built a bunch
of these machines,
and I'll talk a little bit
later about where we're maybe
going to go with them.
One problem is
not anything to do
with the technological
performance, but it's cost.
A typical one like
the Joe Cocker robot
is $250,000 to $400,000, and
you don't make a lot of money
in entertainment doing
that kind of thing.
These are very, very
complicated machines,
and they're sort of
one of many times.
We built 16 robots
for Jurassic Park,
which is a ferocious project
in terms of pain and suffering.
It was really deep fun.
But they were mostly
all different,
and just for the review
of that whole thing,
the things you have to do--
the size of the ranged from
the size of a chicken--
the little compies,
if you remember the movie--
up to 80,000 pounds
for the T-Rex,
and I'll show you
some more about that.
We built 16 systems, plus all
sorts of support equipment.
They're not like movie
machines, which can--
but we could never
build a spider.
Anyway, they're not like movie
machines where you can just
make it run a couple of
times and take 15 shots
and then pick the one you want.
They have wake up
each morning and have
to run essentially 365 days
a year, 16 hours a day,
on and on and on with
silicone skins and so on.
So it's a grueling environment--
water, chemicals, heat, steam,
plants, and on skin exposure,
UVs, direct sunlight, water,
chemicals, mechanical
flexing, and so on-- it's
about the worst environment
you could imagine.
And we were supposed
to have only three
robots that were in water.
And water, by the
way, for anybody
who doesn't design machinery,
is the worst thing on earth.
I mean, it's caused disasters
in our place four times--
distinct, horrible disasters--
because we underestimated
that water can get into
everything and then destroy it.
And so having the skins
on the machines now
and bathed in water is
a very tough situation.
I guess the guys from the
Navy know that because they're
always painting things.
But the movements had
to be fast, graceful,
and impedance-controlled.
The person who did the
programming for that T-Rex--
and that's not the best
program, but that's the only one
I could get--
is a guy named Davy Feiten,
who is famous at Disney.
And he programmed Joe
Cocker, and he also
programmed Buzz Lightyear
for the movie Toy Story.
So he's got a very beautiful
sense of the way things move,
and he did a lot of
the robots there.
So you have to, in addition
to doing the technology,
you have to get an artist
who can see the way things
move very well.
And it's a demanding
design from the standpoint
that everything had to be
approved back and forth
up the chain from Steven
Spielberg, back down
to the lowest person, back
up to Steven Spielberg.
And the reason we did a
lot of the sensor suit work
that you saw, the little
suit to run the wolf,
was actually during the
project in the beginning,
the suit drove every
dinosaur that we had,
and they did
lightly-rendered systems
and would do choreography.
The artists from Universal would
come up and do choreography
on the robot, and then it would
go to Spielberg and his crew
to see if they liked it
and go back and forth
because the hardest
thing in the beginning
was getting a consensus in the
minds of two different kinds
of minds, which were
the technical people
and engineers and the artists.
The artists would say, I want
a really big, mean robot.
And that doesn't mean
that the engineers knew
what they were talking about.
And I'll show you what we
did to try to solve that.
The other thing that
made the project tough
were things like
system complexity,
the kind of movements
and coverings
and so on, many moving parts.
We had this one thing-- when
you see some of these inside,
you'll see they have
enormous steel parts.
And it was because they had this
arbitrary rule we could never
pass was that we
can only use steel,
and we could only go to
5,000 PSI in any weldment.
And so things got big.
There's a lot of surrounding
structures and conduits,
safety of guests and
staff, the time and budget
was short and thin.
The sponsor-- we had 20
different management interfaces
with the company in two years.
And then, so again, it
was this sort of deep fun.
So the way we started out was
generating wireframe models
of all of these systems
into which we put skeletons
with these little red
actuators because we decided
we were never going to get
anywhere with the customer
unless they could shop.
Everybody likes to shop around.
We'd say, this robot's going
to cost a million dollars.
They'd go, what?
And you couldn't do
anything but argue
with them until you could
say, OK, here's a tail,
and this tail has one, two,
three degrees of freedom.
And so it goes like this.
And they'd say, well, we want a
really slinky, serpentine tail.
So you'd build a model
with eight actuators,
and it would go
just like a snake.
And then we'd tell them
that that was 80% more.
They'd say, oh, we
don't want that.
So we'd go back and
forth and back and forth,
and we could make all the
changes in the virtual world.
And what we were doing
that was really interesting
from an engineering standpoint
was generating a database
that everybody agreed with.
We then took these
databases apart,
and the shapes went to the
sculptors, and structures
to structures people,
and the actuators
went to the actuator people
for simulation, and so on.
These are all
hydraulic, but that's
what you need for the
kinds of systems we do.
We'd much rather have had
them be done with electricity.
So here's one of those
pictures of Klaus
with a lightly-rendered spitter.
And it starts with
foams, sculpts--
I thought I had a maquette.
Well, it starts with little
maquettes about this tall
that everybody buys off on.
They could be done
virtually, but they're not.
And then you start
sculpting foam.
This was a guy
named Clay Furches,
which matches what he does.
And this is the T-Rex being
started out of urethane foam.
We're trying to get to the point
where we can digitally machine
those, but we can't right now.
And then, here he is.
He's very committed to his work.
He's doing the
work in the mouth,
but our joke I was telling Woody
is that this is our lawyer.
[LAUGHTER]
But what nobody understands is
he's attacking the dinosaur.
He's got him by the
epliglottis, right?
And here's our sculpting team.
This was the group that was
interesting to watch together
with the engineers, and he
wouldn't fit in our building.
So we had to take
his drumsticks off,
and we did that and then
started building real systems.
And this is him--
pieces of fiberglass,
silicone, and so on.
And then he was
shipped to go together
with this whole system,
which looks like this.
So you saw him come
out of the waterfall.
Well, this big structure holds
him back under the waterfall,
and then he swings out.
This is the waterfall
generator, and to give you
a perspective about
this, this is really more
like construction
equipment because there's
what a person is like.
And that's about where you are
when you go over the falls.
I don't know if you noticed it,
but right as he attacks you,
then you tip over and
you go eight stories down
and come out the bottom,
going lickety-split.
And again, all of this was done
with actually Pro Engineer.
And you can see the actuation
systems and so on that
hold the dinosaur.
And just to show you
one thing I think
that's interesting
about the size
is you can design things
on a screen like this
and just think, well,
it's just a part.
And you see this little
triangle right here.
Well, that little part looks
like this when they deliver it.
And so you can see
the little pins that
are used to put it together
and the little studs where
some of the linkages hook on.
So we actually looked around,
and we had to get the biggest
crane that existed in California
to put pieces of him up
on the top of this 80-foot--
well, actually 120-foot tower.
And we, of course,
analyzed everything
for our little guideline
to not go above 5,000 PSI,
and none of us ever liked that.
So let me just make a few other
comments, some conclusions.
We get a lot of
technical people that
come into the
entertainment group,
and they don't quite understand.
So I told them what
somebody told me--
you've got to remember that
it's the story that counts,
and people come
in, and they just
want to have a great story.
And if you have somebody that
doesn't know how to do it,
run the robot that
was there with Ford,
it falls flat, just like
any entertainment issue.
But if you have an
entertainer like Tommy run it,
then it does better
probably than him alone.
And it's interesting because
the robot is less threatening.
We found various people--
I'd go ask them in the
audience at the Ford pavilion
or the Ford booth at the
auto show why they liked it,
and it was surprising
how many comments
came up that there was--
you could trust it.
I mean, somehow they
trusted the robot.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'd keep digging
into it, but there
were feelings like that, and
there's other funny things
about dinosaurs.
I've been trying to
figure out for years--
why do children like dinosaurs?
And I decided they like
dinosaurs for the same reason I
like a guy who's 6'6" and weighs
300 pounds with tattoos all
over and pulls up on a
Harley and says, who are you?
And I want to make friends.
[LAUGHTER]
You want to make friends
with things like that.
But at any rate, technology
can be the discriminator,
and it can help you have a
monopoly, expanded capability,
and fun.
But it's just not
sufficient, and when
people come to an
engineering school,
you've got to talk to them
about that-- that it's actually
true with the car, too.
It's the story that counts.
It's the car the person
gets to drive, not the fact
that it has better springs.
It's also a team sport.
It requires a mixed set
of broad capabilities,
from artistic, creative
engineering to business.
And it's rough and tough,
and you better believe it.
I'm telling you-- I think if you
look at the kind of people that
run these industries,
they're movie people,
and they're gamblers.
They go, seven, and they
bet $200 million at a whack
with a movie.
And they run it with
horrible schedules.
I really feel bad for them.
It's really a tough life.
Now, you put them together
with a bunch of guys
like our sculptors,
who sit back and say,
this is going to be the most
beautiful piece in the world,
and the clock starts going,
and the money starts running,
and pretty soon the sparks come.
So it's a fairly
tough environment.
Another little comment
about technology
since we're talking about
technology and fun--
It's really confusing
what matters.
Flash in the technology may
not mean true business value,
and there's other things
that dominate, too,
like cost and safety.
And so one thing
I tell people that
are going to go into
this area, you've
got to think about it-- there's
some really better areas.
If you build
catheters for brains,
and you look at the market
size, or the pumps for drugs,
for genetically
engineered drugs--
they talk in some
market surveys--
I don't know if I believe
them-- but by the year 2010,
the worldwide market for
genetically-engineered drugs,
or their application,
is $400 billion a year,
with a third of
every doctor's visit
involving the administration
or use of something related
to genetic engineering,
and the patent protection
is better, and so on.
But in the end, you get
to choose what you do.
And the reason we
keep doing this
is there's this kind of
fun aspect or satisfaction
aspect in doing it.
And so anyway, comments
on the future of where
these things are going--
you see the robots
we have there,
and you see some interactive
devices I didn't show you.
We've got mobility interfaces
you can get on and run around
inside of virtual worlds.
We have these little
shooter systems
that are infrared
two-way communicators,
digital communicators,
but I don't
dare show them on the
East Coast because they're
shaped like guns.
And see, in Utah or in Montana--
my boy went to school
at Montana State,
and as we checked him
in at the front desk,
there was a Xerox
sheet hung there
that said, all students,
check your guns
in at the front counter.
This was two years ago,
and I thought back to MIT--
something different.
But at any rate, we
make little shooters
that you can point and designate
complicated commands to.
And if you really think
about where things are going,
they're going with displays,
interfaces, computation,
and communication--
in other words,
how to take a person
into the environment.
In the little system we did--
well, I'll show it to you--
at Buffalo Bill's, it's
a flume ride.
We made these.
Now, this is the shape
they wanted because it's
the Six-Gun Western place.
And this little gun does
an infrared communication
with targets, and so
it turned their ride
into sort of a shooting gallery.
And so there's all
sorts of things
going on with
computers and so on,
but in the end, that's kind
of fun because you go through,
and what's really interesting
is some of the bad guys that are
there will shoot you back.
The kids really like
it because they'll
shoot one of the bad
guys, and he comes up
and squirt them with a
squirt gun in the face.
So there's going to be
more and more interaction
in all of these areas.
And so a lot of the things
that go along with computers
are going to help in the area.
A lot of mixed
environments and also
needs for rapidly-changeable
attractions--
you can no longer in that
business get a Ferris wheel
and let it sit
there and sit there
without adding new attractions.
I think most theme
parks try to have
a major attraction added
every year and a minor one
in between years.
And technology can help with
making variable attractions,
especially if you do things
with a virtual environment.
If the displays get better, you
can have more changeability.
Also, the possibility of mobile
systems that can move around--
what you'd really
like to do is permit
the use of more
expensive capital assets
in smaller attractions but
not have them go stale.
If you go to a
smaller attraction,
and then you go back
there two or three times--
I don't know how many
people do that here,
but your kids probably do.
If the same stuff is there,
then you don't go back.
And also, another area
that's going to expand a lot
is personal ownership
by the guests.
So they own the system that
they use and can take it home
with them or bring it back.
In the case of
these, we're going
to do a thing with
something like this.
It won't look like
a gun anymore.
It'll be a personal communicator
for the Ford pavilion.
We're going to also do
some of these in casinos.
So when you check in,
you get this little box,
and the little box is yours.
And you can download money
into it, which isn't new,
but it'll be new in
this environment.
And you can use it to open your
room and play keno and gamble
or order your car
up from the valet,
and the system will have
all the information in it
relative to you and be cheap
enough for you to own yourself.
So at any rate,
that's sort of a look
at the fun side of what we do.
Are there any questions,
because we have three minutes?
I think.
Oh, these are the only two.
Well, then I guess I'm supposed
to introduce Seymour Papert,
and then I'll vacate
the stage here.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PAPERT: Hi.
Well, I see you can't
get away from technology.
I'm not going to
show you any pictures
because it's obviously
impossible to outdo
what you've just seen.
Also, maybe I'm going to be
rather more serious than I
usually am and the other
speakers because usually,
when I talk about technology,
I try to say it's for fun.
It's for a special kind
of fun for children,
a special kind of
fun called hard fun.
And so usually, people don't
think of technology like that,
and so I try to inject the fun.
But I think this time, I'd
like to inject the serious side
and suggest that we
are really not taking
our children and the
technologies that they can use
as seriously as we ought to.
And by we, I mean all of you.
I certainly mean our
society and people
who think about what I'd like to
call the learning environment.
You see, we are
slaves to technology.
I was asked to move
into a place that's more
convenient for that camera.
But it doesn't seem to be
working any better, anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so I'd like
to start by giving
a couple of little anecdotes
that I like to tell.
Anecdote one-- you see
your grandchild, age three,
walk up to a shelf,
pick out a videotape,
and go and put it in the
VCR, press on some buttons
and say some expletive
deleted, which
means he forgot to rewind it.
He rewinds it fluently
without hesitating a moment
and spends the next
half hour immersed
in whatever it is-- dinosaurs
or road construction machines
or whatever it might be.
And I'd like to reflect a
little about the significance
of that kind of incident.
People often say, well,
isn't that amazing
that a 3-year-old can do all
that, can work that technology?
And when it's a two-year-old,
and he's clicking on a mouse
and making a computer
program play,
they are even more
inclined to say, gee, wow.
But in fact, if you think of the
complexity of what that kid is
doing, either of
those kids, it's
nothing compared with what they
do all the time just knowing
where their toys are
kept, how to get them out
of their closet, how to
put them away at the end--
unlikely, but they know how
to do it if they wanted to.
[LAUGHTER]
What we see them doing with
these computers and VCRs
is very simple
compared with that,
so that's not the side
of it that's impressive.
What really is impressive is--
well, for me and for anybody
even half my age, I think--
when I was three
years old, there
was no way in which I could
decide to spend the next half
hour immersed in dinosaurs
or road construction
machines or anything that
might have interested me.
I could explore everything
within reach and touch
inside the place where I lived,
but anything beyond that,
I was totally
dependent on adults.
I could asked them
about dinosaurs.
They might be able
to tell me, and they
might be willing to tell me, but
it's not the same experience,
anyway.
And I think that this
is a little pointer
to a deep, deep transformation
that is taking place
in the relationship between
children, knowledge, adults,
family, society.
And it needs to be
taken very seriously.
There's a lot of
talk in the papers,
and when people
get on to talking
about the worldwide
web and the internet,
about the danger,
pornography, predators-- there
are obvious dangers.
People are scared of
letting their kids loose
in this cyber world.
And there's reasons for
a lot of those fears.
But I'd like to
suggest that they
miss the point, that people
worried about pornography
on the internet--
this is just symbolic.
They are really worried
about something much deeper
that they maybe
haven't articulated.
And that deeper thing is
questions of dependence
and independence and
the amount of control
they have or want to have over
their kids and the control
that the kids have
or want to have
or the parents want them to
have over the world and life.
Kids are getting access to
vastly greater and different
kinds of dependence
and independence.
And this is something
that, I think,
is going far enough
already to make
it irresponsible for people
not to be thinking very
hard about rethinking
what parenting is about,
what the family is
about, what being a child
is about, what we
expect from children.
That the children can
wander off and might
run into a picture of
a naked person or worse
is really part of
this larger question
that children are less
dependent on their adults
and becoming less and less so.
And what is the
implication of that?
Nobody really knows.
And I don't think
they're just talking
about it's going to
solve the problem,
but at least it's a step.
I'd like to look at
this from a slightly
sort of more academic point of
view, generalized point of view
by outlining a different
kind of theory of stages
in individual development
in relation to knowledge
and learning.
Stage one-- a baby is born.
And from day one, if
not before, that baby
begins an active
process of exploration--
first, its own body,
its mother's body.
It begins to crawl and
explores the world.
And all this is producing an
incredible lot of learning.
That baby is learning very
thoroughly a very limited
world, that immediate reality.
But it's learning it
in a particular way,
note-- this particular
way is by exploration,
through experience,
driven from inner desire.
Everything that's done is
meaningful to that child.
That's stage one.
Stage two begins when the child
sees a dinosaur and says, well,
how did dinosaurs eat?
Or what happened to them?
Or whatever question might
be asked about the dinosaur--
this child has run into inside
the little immediate world,
has run into questions about
the bigger world out there.
And the child has
no way to answer
those questions except, well,
fantasy that can go freely,
and that's wonderful, but is not
related, not rooted in reality.
Or asking adults
or accidentally,
it so happens that there
is a piece on television
or the mother happens to
read a book, but on the whole
the child is helpless in
getting that knowledge.
And so we gradually
get a shift in the mode
of learning from experiential
to verbal because they are
going to ask and get answers--
it's all in words.
And bit by bit, it moves
away from your agenda
to somebody else's agenda,
and the ultimate of that
is school, where it's entirely
somebody else's agenda.
There's the curriculum,
and that's what you learn,
and somebody else is going to
decide here are the textbooks,
and there's all this
set-out knowledge
that somebody has decided that
that's what you should know.
And so you go to
school, and you go
through the traumatic
experience of--
well, I'm going to say
this outrageous thing,
but I really mean it--
giving up learning and
adapting to being taught.
And being taught is not
the same as learning.
Well, you go through
school, and it's
a precarious little journey.
It's more precarious
than anybody in this room
is likely to know, because
you wouldn't be in this room
if you weren't one of those
who survived the journey.
[LAUGHTER]
Most people don't.
And most people in the
course of this journey
have that drive to learn,
curiosity, explore, to know,
to be independent that
babies are all born with.
They have it attenuated,
and it's gone,
and that's just a fact.
Now those who survived get
something wonderful out
of school, namely they get new
ways of access to independence.
You learn to read, you'll learn
to not just read the letters,
to use encyclopedias and
libraries and conversations
and all the rest of the
means of access to knowledge,
and eventually,
you get to a place
where you go back to stage
one, and that stage three.
The closest thing I
know to the stage one
child in those first
couple of years
is the best work by
graduate students
or the best work
in a research lab
or the best and most creative
work in making Jurassic Park
or creating a business
or independent people
really being creative,
following their own ideas,
learning what they need to
know when they need to know it,
knowing from experience.
And so I think we really
do, in an important sense,
go back to stage three--
in stage three go
back to stage one.
Well, what my story about the
videotape is really pointing to
is that technology
is getting to a place
where it can bypass stage two.
As we are getting to a
place where there need not
be that discontinuity,
where reading books,
encyclopedias in
printed written form
no longer are the major
and only form of access
to a broader knowledge
and the broader world.
And the videotape is just a
hint at what is already coming
and what's around the
corner, that with more
and more of them,
with video on demand,
with the world wide web, with
just the beginnings of search
engines that are not
formulated, that don't require,
that are not text-based,
and their categories
are not the categories
that interest, no doubt.
We are beginning to see
organizations of people trying
to make interfaces accessible
to preschool children
independently of reading and
writing so that they are now
just about beginning to get
across the threshold of access
to knowledge, and ultimately
better knowledge, more
detailed knowledge, easier
access to knowledge than can be
found in printed books,
for all the reasons
that make the electronic
interactive media more
effective.
This is not just
in its projection
a supplement to reading and
writing or just another medium.
It is a vastly superior medium.
Of course, that will
subsume reading and writing,
and it will always include
text in the foreseeable future,
anyway.
But it will no longer be
true that so-called literacy,
that I'd rather
call letteracy, is
the essential road towards being
able to get more knowledge.
I think that we ought to
question very seriously,
and we will be sort of forced
to question more seriously
the importance that we give
in our school years to those
so-called three rs--
reading, writing,
and arithmetic.
Well, I think reading
is going to be
important for a long
time, but I would
foresee that it will stop having
that primordial importance
that it's had.
I don't think kids
will give up reading.
As a matter of
fact, my prediction
is that if we stop
trying to make kids read,
they would learn to read
much more because I think
a lot of the problems
that kids have
about reading is that parents
and teachers get so upset when
this kid is not reading
on time, according
to some timetable that's
been set by somebody else,
that they develop these
tensions, and they are worried,
and the kid senses
all this, and there's
a whole psychological cascade
of events that frustrate
good, free, relaxed learning.
And so we self-generate
this remarkable epidemic
that has invaded the world
that just didn't exist 30
or 40 years ago called learning
disabilities, dyslexia,
and all the rest of it.
Well, so when we look at the
way that our education world is
thinking about technology
in relation to learning,
it's, to my mind, shockingly
different from the implications
of the picture I've
been trying to give you.
I'm not talking
about what you will
see in schools all
over the place, where
somehow the idea that we
will use these computers
to improve a little bit or a
lot the same kind of teaching
of the same kind of material on
roughly the same sort of time
scale.
Well, that's the way in
which all technologies first
enter the world.
And Jurassic Park
we just looked at,
and the first use
of a movie camera
wasn't anything like that.
The first movie was well, you
had this wonderful camera.
You said, well, this is
technology-aided theater,
so act a play and put
the camera in front of it
and make the first movie.
So you're using it
to improve, to make
a slightly better
version of something
that you've been
doing all along.
And that's about where we were
at in our uses of computers
in schools.
At least they're not harmful.
Where I think they
are harmful, where
that idea of how to use
computers is very harmful
is in what's happening to
children whose families own
computers and who buy the
so-called education software
that's flooding the market.
And this is why I think
it's actually harmful
because I see that transition
from stage one to stage two.
In the past, it's
been a necessary evil,
let's say, a
necessary price to pay
because we had no
way in which children
could continue the
kind of learning
that happens before school.
Let's call it home-style
learning or natural learning.
We had no way in which
that learning could
encompass all the
knowledge we thought
children ought to have--
incorrectly thought that.
So we instituted something else
called school-style learning.
And there was a
necessary evil, and it's
an extremely dangerous thing.
And it's an inferior
kind of learning,
as evidenced by the
fact that none of you,
if you need to know something,
go and take a course in it.
You read the newspaper.
You read the financial
reports if you
want to make an investment.
You don't submit yourself to
somebody else's curriculum
in a school.
So why do we put
children through it?
Because they don't
have any choice.
But now, a new
thing is happening,
and that is most parents--
certainly most
educated parents-- now
have computers at home,
and a new kind of question
is coming up for them.
Previously, it was a division
of labor that children--
certain kinds of things,
they learned at home.
They learned to talk.
They learned to walk, to
find their way around space,
get around the house, get around
the parents, for that matter,
learn to be psychologically
manipulative
and get some insight into
psychology-- all this stuff
they learned in home.
On the other hand, stuff like
what we call math at school--
I just can't bring myself
to call it mathematics.
This stuff was the job
of teachers and schools.
Parents never bothered
much about it,
except when they got
a bad report card,
and they had a conference
with the teacher.
Now, all of a
sudden, parents are
being flooded with advertising
saying, buy this CD-ROM.
It will teach your child.
It will be such fun.
She won't even know
that she's learning.
she's doing math.
And there's several aspects
of that that I think are bad.
One of them is that parents are
being asked to make decisions
about issues that they
haven't thought about,
and they're not
qualified to make.
Although that's
the lesson there.
If they would really
throw off their prejudices
and just think, they
would do much better.
But what, in fact,
they are doing
is succumbing to
the marketing device
that you will sell
best as software that
has these characteristics--
it must look
like school because in
many people's minds,
school is the
safest way to think
about what's good learning.
It will serve a
babysitter function
by keeping the kid focused there
without you having to bother
about, without bothering you.
And it should be--
well, it comes the
same thing again--
it should be just
run independently.
The kid shouldn't have
to ask many questions.
And it shouldn't plant too many
bad ideas in the child's mind,
either.
So you buy this stuff.
It's the best-selling
software, and what you're doing
is importing into the
home those early years,
the kinds of learning and
the habits of learning
that previously belonged
to the school years,
and nobody knows how
bad a thing that is.
I suspect it's a very
bad thing, and I'd
like to emphasize that
by telling another story
about a grandchild.
A little while
ago, I spent a day
in the school of my then 6
and 1/2 year old grandchild.
I sort of hung out in school.
I didn't sit next to
him, but I kept an eye
on what he was doing.
Two things that struck
me that I'd seen often--
maybe I should have said
earlier, I do a lot of--
for the last quite
a number of years,
I've been increasingly
spending my time thinking
about what computers
can mean for children.
I've done a lot
of work in schools
and done projects in them and
hung around in schools a lot.
So it's not a new experience
for me to go into a school,
but I hadn't done it
for awhile, and it
was a new experience for me
to go into a school thinking
about one individual child
whom I knew very, very well.
And the two things that
struck me were these.
First of all, it looked
like a different person.
This kid I know as an
intellectually intense, highly
energetic, vibrantly energetic
person who gets passionately
interested in things, and
you can't take him away
from the things he's
doing and he wants to do.
Computers, yes.
Video games, yes.
But growing vegetables, he
was fascinated by for a while.
He's involved in cooking.
He's involved in some
very big projects
and building out of LEGO--
high-quality stuff,
self-directed.
I go into school, and I
see the first thing strikes
me is that this
level of intensity--
instead of being up there,
it's down there somewhere.
It's a kind of low, laid
back, not much is happening.
Most of the time
they're sitting around,
or when they're
paying attention,
they're sort of
paying attention.
They have little
bursts of energy.
There's a good teacher who
sometimes sort of turns them on
for a while.
But taken over the
whole day, I would
say that in terms of energy
level, it's about 10%
of what I see this kid,
and that bothers me.
And I think it's characteristic
of the nature of school
and the nature of
that shift we're
making in kinds of learning.
And then the other thing
that bothered me was related,
but I think a different
thing, and that
was a corruption of values.
And I think school,
in its nature,
is deeply corrupting in values.
And in this, the example
of that particularly
struck me was intellectual
honesty and goals.
This kid at home and
before going to school
would do things
because he thought
they were important and had
a real personal commitment
to doing them and would
defend it, sometimes
much to the causing a lot
of trouble for his parents.
Now in school, instead of doing
things that came from his heart
and came from deep commitment
that he believed in,
he was doing things
because he got a check
mark in a book or a star,
or a teacher approved of it.
So he's being shifted
from acting out
of conviction to acting out
of getting external approval.
I can't imagine any worse
moral corruption than that.
And it's intrinsic in
our school system--
some schools worse than others.
But it's not them--
some teachers manage to
overcome this entirely.
I'm not talking about that.
Wonderful things happen in some
classrooms by some teachers.
But if you think
about the nature
of that system as a whole, these
are qualities of that system.
Well, how could it be different?
How can technology
make it different?
I've mentioned one way in which
access to computers and the web
and things like that
make a difference,
and I want to mention
another, which
I think is just as important,
maybe more important.
The two that I'm
going to mention
get their importance
by being put together.
The one that I've
mentioned already
is what's become the
popular kind of synonym
for what computer stuff and
the network and all this
is about-- it's information.
It's information
technology, we even call it.
Well, that's a wrong
approach, I think,
because of what I'm going
to talk about in a moment.
In 1967, I first came to
MIT, and before coming here,
I'd had a lot of contact with
Jean Piaget, a great child
psychologist in Switzerland.
I was a mathematician.
When I came to MIT, I'd played
with computers a little.
This was in 1964.
I'd played with a few
computers in Europe
and had a little
contact with them.
I came to MIT, and I was
waiting for Marvin Minsky
to turn up late for an
appointment, and there he was.
Next to his office
was a computer.
In fact, it was the first model
of Digital Equipment's PDP-1.
Well, maybe it was number two--
a very early, early prototype.
And I was sitting there, so I
just started fiddling with it,
and fiddled with it
for about an hour.
And when Minsky came in,
I sort of apologized.
I said, I've been playing
with his computer.
He looked at me in amazement
and said, well, of course.
That's what it's there for.
And this idea that you could
just take this computer
and just fool with it
was totally alien to me,
and for a long
time, it was going
to become alien to most
people's ideas of computers.
But of course, now we
have personal computers,
and that's the standard model.
Playing with that
computer, I suddenly
found out that I could
take some problems that
had been bothering me for
years, and with this computer,
I could get a whole new insight.
And in a few days, I cleaned
up a whole bunch of problems
that had been on my agenda.
And this was a
revelatory experience.
And in fact, that's what caused
me to decide to come to MIT.
There was what I referred to
as a short two-week visit,
and then because of this, I
accepted a two-year invitation,
and that turned into
the rest of my life.
I'm still here.
But this revelation
planted the seed in my mind
that I'd been worrying
for years before that
about how can the learning
of children change.
And all of a sudden,
there it was.
It seemed that here is the way.
If children could only have
that enormous amplification
of power, that exhilarating
experience of intellectual
empowerment that
I had just getting
at that what I see now as an
incredibly primitive computer.
If children could
only get at that,
that could change their patterns
of intellectual development.
And that became a little
obsession of mine, and right
through the '60s and '70s, when
the idea of children actually
getting at a computer, except
in specially artificial set-ups,
some of which we
were responsible for,
seemed very remote.
And I was accused by,
when I wrote proposals
trying to get funds
to support it,
they ranged from
romantic to elitist.
I mean, maybe a few
millionaires' children
will be able to
benefit from this,
but it won't change the world.
Well, it has changed the
world, and in all that time--
it's now 30 years--
a main thrust of our work that
was the Artificial Intelligence
Lab.
And then when the
Media Lab got founded,
I was one of the original group
in founding the Media Lab,
and we transferred our
activities into there
and continued until now.
And the thrust of
our work is not
the computer as an
information source
nor the computer as a
kind of automated teacher
that treats the child as a kind
of answering machine-- now,
what's seven plus eight?
You're right.
You wrong.
Next question, next answer.
We'd like to think
of the computer
as a medium of construction.
We saw those pictures of robots.
We have children making--
they're not as
elaborate as that.
We're beginning to
have children being
able to make that kind of
robot in a simplified form.
We have children
programming the computer,
making their own
video games, if that's
what they're interested in.
That is, they are
taking this technology
and using it as a
constructive medium
to carry out
projects that are not
any more complex than
children have ever
been able to do
in the past except
on the psychological
plane of learning to maybe
be part of a family.
But in terms of having
matter and projects
with the technical scientific
and mathematical content,
until recently,
there was very little
that a child could do that had
serious content of that sort
that could be carried out
as a long-term project
so that you could get the
feel of what it's like to make
something really complex
work and run into the bugs
and difficulties that
we saw a sample of
and how to deal with now to
construct these Jurassic Park
robots.
In doing this, we've
worked with companies.
We worked especially with
LEGO, the makers of LEGO,
and one of the thrusts
of our work with LEGO
has been developing a tiny
little computer which you could
put inside a LEGO
model and sensors
so this computer could
know about the environment,
could detect light,
sound, touch, heat.
And so you could make out of
LEGO extended in this way,
you could make a real
robot that would really
do something under
its own control
with its little brain inside it.
And that's been a
long, long haul,
and I believe that
early next year
or late this year,
they're actually
going to put one of these
devices on the market.
But in the last 15
years, we've been
working with children
with prototypes of this,
and we've actually got
some fancier ones that
are much smaller, and it's quite
amazing what children can do.
As examples of
that kind of thing,
I worked one summer with two
girls-- one about six to seven,
and the other about eight.
And we worked together
on several afternoons
a week for several
weeks in the summer.
What they wanted to make was a
cat and a kitten out of LEGO.
And they sort of dressed them
up, and they made whiskers.
But also, inside the cat and
the kitten was real behavior.
They were not only
constructing structures,
they were actually
constructing behavior.
And the behavior they wanted
was when the kitten squeaked,
the cat would come to it.
Well, how do you do that?
Engineers know how to do that.
Hardly anybody in
our society who
hasn't been through engineering
school knows how to do that,
but six-year-olds can
know how to do that.
And they can understand
ideas of how to use sensors,
how to use the idea of feedback,
how to control a process,
how to do all sorts
of stuff that we
teach in college-level
engineering courses on control
engineering.
They can do it, and
this kind of stuff
is more accessible and easier
to learn than the dead language
kind of mathematics we try
to teach them in school,
and it includes it, because
in the course of working
on making these
devices, they run
into fractions and decimals
and shapes and configurations
and all the things
that are normally
treated like a dead language
in the school math and science
classes.
They learn like a
living language,
like living in the country.
So they learn math like
living in Mathland,
which is the place which is
to mathematics like France
is to French, where you learn
the language by speaking it,
not by being taught
it in a classroom.
And we see in this
a transformation
of the kind of play activities
that children can do.
But now to say
something about play--
when I looked into that
school, what struck me,
even when there was activity
that the teachers called play,
I wouldn't call that play.
It was play play.
It was play play play.
It wasn't even real play because
real play is the intensity
that my little grandson had
when he was really engaged.
Real play is the intensity
that my graduate students
have when they are really
immersed in a project,
playing with ideas
and are trying
to explore and decide
how to do something,
getting really excited.
There's a kind of play
that we usually call work,
and that's why I think
this title that I
tried to give this talk of
play as child's work is--
I think it points to a degree of
seriousness about serious play.
And serious play
isn't making the child
a kind of too-serious
person who doesn't know
how to laugh and fool around.
On the contrary, it's full of
laughing and fooling around,
just like the best work is.
So I think these two
things come together.
An example of how they
might come together
is a graduate student
working under my direction
now, Michele Evard, is
doing a project that's
a prime example of how these
two sides of the information
process come together.
She's working in an inner-city
elementary school in Boston,
where for a number of years
we've had enough computers
so that kids can have,
say, an hour or two a day
working at the computers.
And they do all sorts
of things with them,
but one kind of
project that we've
tried to foster there
is a project where,
for a whole year for
that hour a day, say,
you'll be working
on our project.
So you get a feel of
what it's like to pursue
a project over a long
enough period of time
for it to inhabit you,
so that when you wake up
in the morning, you
get an idea for it.
So that you've got enough
time to try something out,
find it's wrong, and
then try something else.
The kind of project
that we've done
many kinds of projects, some
of them involving this LEGO.
This particular research
investigation of Michele Evard
is about one that I mentioned
before-- making your own video
game.
The kids are going
to make a game,
and together with
the game, they're
going to make the advertising
material with the instruction
book for how to use it.
They're going to
present at the end
of the year at a
kind of game fair
where they and other
kids and parents
and anyone who wants
to come will come,
and they will each try to
sell their particular game.
Well, one of the problems about
that way of learning is access.
Where does the
information come from?
And how do you get an
answer to a question?
There you are trying
to make something move,
make a figure jump.
And you think,
well, what's a jump?
What's it look like?
And how do you describe it?
Well, you say, teacher,
teacher, but the teacher's
only got limited knowledge
and only limited time.
What Michele Evard's
project is about
is breaking down this
incredible inefficiency
of having one teacher to
30 learners or 20 learners.
It's crazy.
Why don't we have 30
teachers and 30 learners?
Well, this is a move
in that direction,
that if you're stuck
with this problem,
you might ask the kid next to
you, you might ask the teacher,
but if you don't get
something immediate,
there's another route that
you might prefer, anyway.
She's constructed a
kind of net system.
You throw your question
into cyberspace,
so you put it in the computer.
And then there's a
community of people
that might include kids who
did this the year before,
or it might include a
kid at the other end
of the class who
you've never spoken to,
or somebody outside altogether.
But you throw your
problem out, and then we
see that there are a lot
of kids who really enjoy
acting as consultants and
picking up other people's
problems and thinking
about them and drawing
on their own experience.
And we've noticed
through getting
this access to being able
to consult with this larger
community, a very marked
improvement in the quality
of the work these kids can do.
So we see them putting
the two things together.
This is a kind of net
information access,
person access kind of
function with having
a real, hard, technical
kind of project to work on.
Put them together, and the
kind of mindless surfing
of the web that
you often get gets
replaced by a purposeful
search for information
that you need for a project
you're really engage in.
And both come up,
and we're beginning
to see a kind of
chemical reaction
there that I think is
a little model of what
the alternative to so-called
curriculum-based environment,
curriculum-based
learning will be.
And I think that
curriculum-based learning
is going to disappear.
Certainly, what I'm
sure will disappear
is this perverse idea that
we should segregate people
by ages and levels of knowledge.
Yeah, it's amazing how
we take it for granted
that it's natural that
you should be first grade,
all these kids together; second
grade, all these kids together.
Why?
I mean, if I told you
to segregate yourself,
and I won't talk to you unless
everybody between 20 and 25
sits there--
you'd think I was crazy,
and you wouldn't do it.
Why do we do this in school?
Now there's only one reason,
and that is that in the past,
the only way we had of
getting this knowledge out
was systematizing it
and spoon-feeding it
in a kind of
industrial production.
So what we're seeing there
is a production line,
an old industrial-style
production line.
And there's no other
justification for it.
And people say, if you ask them,
well, it's for socialization.
Gosh, well, it sounds
to me like what
happens is when
you're seven, you
spend your whole seventh
year learning how
to deal with kids of age seven.
And then in typical
school fashion,
you never deal with that again.
Having learned it, you
get onto the next thing,
and you never see a
seven-year-old again,
but now you've got to learn
to deal with eight-year-olds.
[LAUGHTER]
What this deprives
you of is that mixture
of skills and levels of
understanding where people
can be in a real
learning community
where people who know a lot
and people who know a little
are all together, and each
side learns and expands
their knowledge by
exchanging with the others.
And everywhere, that's
the better thing to do.
It's not only in this
meeting and your lives,
it's in these great
old extended families
that we so deplore
the disappearance of.
In one place, there would be
parents, children, grandparents
all together, living together.
And we thought it was wonderful
that these communities existed,
and we deplore the fact
they're disappearing.
But they weren't
segregated by age.
Everybody got richer
lives and richer learning
because they were all together.
And I think the perversion of--
well, it's not a perversion.
It's only a perversion
if you think that that's
the natural thing to do.
I want to recognize the
whole structure of school,
the idea of grades,
the idea of curriculum
is a way of dealing
with a now-obsolete or
rapidly-becoming obsolescent
kind of relationship
with knowledge and
its dissemination,
and all that should go.
So technology and
education doesn't mean
using it to improve the system.
It's very hard to get this
through people's heads.
I give talks like this to
meetings of superintendents
of schools, and at
the end, somebody
says, but tell me concretely,
how do you think in the year
2020 we will teach,
use computers to teach
the fourth-grade
math curriculum?
And you'll want to
tear your hair out.
There won't be any fourth grade.
We won't be teaching.
We'll be learning.
There won't be a separate
subject called math.
It will be part of--
but these categories are
so deeply ingrained in us,
we need a serious
struggle to break out,
and that's something that
we can all do and make
a big difference in the world
by fighting these categories
and just calling
them in question.
And maybe we don't even
have to say they're wrong.
You only have to say,
well, think about it.
Have you thought about whether
they could be gotten away with?
I'm going to use the rest of
my time on that word world.
And it's impossible to talk
about things like this,
about the role of technology
and expensive machinery,
without facing the fact
that the world doesn't
consist of economically
homogeneous people.
There are about 20 countries
in the world in which I would
say there's a
process afoot that's
bringing computers and
connectivity into the lives
of most children.
They don't all get it,
and we're very far from it
in the United
States, and we should
be thoroughly
ashamed of ourselves
that our President can
stand up and suggest
that putting one
computer in each school
or in each classroom is a worthy
objective for our country.
A computer on every
desk and another one
in every home for every child
would be maybe a little better,
and we could afford it.
But anyway, past that, there
are 180 other countries
in the world where the chance
of children getting access
to any of this is extremely
slim unless something is done.
And so a few of us have started
a foundation which we call 2B1.
Does that technology work?
You can look on its
website, www.2B1.org.
The goal of this
foundation is to promote
every way we can find
of bringing access
to computers and connectivity to
those parts of the world where,
for reasons of geographic
isolation, poverty,
political opposition,
whatever the reason,
where there are obstacles.
And the first action of this
foundation is going to happen
this July, when we're going
to try to bring together right
here-- well, not in this
room, but in this campus--
we're trying to round
up at the moment
100 activists from
developing countries.
And by activists, we mean
people who, out there,
against all odds, have done
something bringing computers
to kids where it seemed
very unlikely that they
would get them.
And the more what they
did is Mission Impossible,
the more we like them, and
we're trying to cast out a net
and get 100 such people
and invite them in here.
And we would have a six-day
brainstorming workshop where
the 100 activists--
together with 100
other people who
come along with
technological knowledge,
with experience in
organizing, with ideas
about learning, with ideas about
funding, with other resources--
can come together in
a mix from which we
would like to
generate new ideas,
spreading the ideas
that already exist.
The beginnings of a
community formation
of trying to move
this extension of,
move this wonderful thing we
call digital technology out
of the range of the
elite, the elite countries
and elite people within
countries, to that wider world.
And we sort of feel,
romantic as it might sound,
that children come
into the world
without a sense of
hatred, isolation,
and that they want to
preserve the environment,
and they like the
world they live in.
And if we can get children into
a new kind of internationalism
through knowing more about the
world, through connectivity
and knowing more about
ways of knowledge that
have been our privilege, this
might make a better world.
And so the name 2B1--
you can read it all
sorts of ways you like,
but written like that expresses
a political and social ideology
as well as an intent
to do something,
to change the learning
environment of the planet.
So an appeal-- look at that.
If you know people, or if
you have any contact anywhere
so we can find one
more of these activists
in some unlikely place, you'll
be doing a real service--
not just to us and to
yourself, but to everybody
and next generations
of this planet.
I think that's the time
I'm supposed to stop,
so I'll stop there.
I don't know how many minutes
there are for questions.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
CRAWLEY: I think it's time for
that fine tradition in baseball
called the seventh
inning stretch.
So if you'd just like to stand
in your seat for one second--
OK, that's long enough.
Now you can sit down.
Thank you very much.
I'm Ed Crawley.
That really was just a second.
Welcome to Technology Day.
I'm Ed Crawley.
I'm the rocket scientist
here at MIT, the real one.
I'm the head of the
Aero-Astro Department,
and what I'd like
to talk to you today
about is airplanes, baseballs,
and the fun of flight.
Now to commemorate
this event, I've
worn my baseball cap, which
I wear when I'm flying,
or is it my flying cap that
I wear when I play baseball?
I'm not quite sure.
What do we do at MIT?
We develop technology, and we
invent things that never were.
[LAUGHTER]
Isn't that what we do?
Science is the discovery of
things that always have been.
Technology as the inventions
of things that never were--
Theodore von Kármán.
We encourage learning.
Sometimes we call this teaching.
But of course, the real
objective is learning.
We make contributions
to society,
and we form the future.
Those are modest goals that
we have here with technology.
Well, that's what we do, and
that's the outline of my talk.
So first, to have a
short advertisement,
I'd like to tell you
about my department, which
is called Aero-Astro,
Aeronautics and Astronautics,
course 16, whose objectives
are to advance and disseminate
knowledge of the principles
and conception, design,
implementation, and operation
of things within its domain.
And its domain starts
here and goes up.
So it includes aircraft,
launch vehicles, spacecraft,
things that go on the
surface of the moon,
things that go on
the surface of Mars,
photons which pass
through that medium--
we're in the
telecommunication business--
and, of course, baseballs,
softballs, tennis balls,
and such.
Now is this a surprise
that we should
think about sports and
baseballs in the Department
of Aeronautics and Astronautics?
I don't think so.
Go out on Briggs Field
on a Saturday afternoon,
and what do you find
the students doing?
Enjoying themselves
by playing sports.
They go home, they watch sports.
You know, of course, all
the dorms are now wired
with cable TV and the web.
And of course, we know
what they use those for,
which is not getting their
homework assignments.
It's really watching the
Saturday afternoon baseball
game.
Well Aero-Astro is
also exciting and cool.
The students really love it.
We get students
in our department
who by and large are
those students who
rode their bicycle down to the
airport when they were young
and watched the
airplanes take off,
who played hooky from school to
watch the space vehicles take
off.
There's an excitement
about our business,
as there's an
excitement about sports.
Sports, if you haven't
noticed, are pretty high-tech.
The second largest consumer
of graphite epoxy and titanium
materials in the United
States, for example,
as a measure of
high-tech material usage,
is the sporting goods industry.
The largest usage of
graphite epoxy and titanium
in the United States is
the Aero-Astro business.
And if you really wanted
to build a sporting good--
I just happen to have one
here that I'll talk about
later-- if you really
wanted to build this,
what would you
need to know about?
Well, you'd need to know
about lightweight structures.
It has to be light.
Aerodynamics-- it has
to pass through the air.
Human factors-- it has
to have a good grip,
can't give you tennis elbow.
Information-- maybe.
How long will it be before
you buy a tennis racket
with a microprocessor in it?
[LAUGHTER]
A year or two.
And of course, you have
to know about design.
And what do you need to do
to know about Aero-Astro,
to build things in Aero-Astro?
You need to know about
lightweight structures,
like airplanes and
spacecraft; aerodynamics
to pass through the atmosphere;
human factors in order
to satisfy the
pilots; information
processing and flow;
and, of course, design.
So is it any surprise that
people who do Aero-Astro
are also interested
in sporting equipment?
It shouldn't be.
In fact, when I took a poll
in preparation for this talk,
I found that more than 50% of
the faculty in our department
had an avocational interest
in sporting good design.
They had consulted.
They had designed.
They had helped set
standards, and so forth.
So I want to show
you a little bit
about the technology of sports.
We'll have the first video.
This is a high-speed
photo of a skier,
and I want you to look at
the amount of vibration
there is in these skis.
Watch this.
In fact, you turn on skis.
You turn on the edge of skis--
we all know that.
But you actually turn
on the edge of skis--
look at this guy's
leg, by the way.
If you don't think there
isn't human factors
going on in there.
You turn on this
edge of a ski that's
on contact with the snow.
But you can look at this
and see that there's usually
about a centimeter
of displacement
between the snow
and the ski edge.
Look at this guy's leg.
Skis, structures,
dynamics, human factors.
Watch the tennis ball go by.
That was in modestly
slow motion.
You're a line judge
at the US Open,
and you have to
call that, right?
Now, here it is in slow-mo.
And those two little lines,
of course, represent the line.
This is human perception
and ball dynamics.
The rule actually is if any
of the footprint of the ball
touches the line, it's in.
But the human eye can resolve
about five milliseconds,
and this dynamic event
is significantly short--
I'm sorry, 20 milliseconds.
The dynamic event of this
is about five seconds.
There's the footprint.
Was that ball in or out?
That ball was in, but if you
just saw it at that glimpse,
it was out.
Here's a bow, one of the
oldest tools of mankind.
There's the arrow going off.
Watch the dynamics of the bow,
and particularly this piece
right in here.
Never would have thought that
a bow shook around that much.
Now watch this.
This is an absolutely
amazing shot
by this archer, who
is going to shoot
an arrow, which is right
about in there, towards us.
Watch out, Doc.
Here it comes.
He's about to release
it right there.
There's the release.
Watch the arrow.
[LAUGHTER]
It's the highest-stiffness arrow
that's made, a graphite fiber
shaft arrow.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --away from the club's
center of gravity,
giving the club a very high
resistance to twisting.
CRAWLEY: Listen to the claims.
- Thus, off-centered hits do not
twist a metal-wood club as much
as conventional wood.
Less twisting,
reduced torque results
in straighter shots
and increased distance.
CRAWLEY: May be true or may not.
- The external weight placement
in metal-wood also allows
the weight to be placed lower
and farther behind the ball
than a conventional wood.
The resulting lower
center of gravity
creates a more efficient energy
transfer of the club head's
mass through the ball for
more consistent, longer hits.
CRAWLEY: May be true, may not.
- The metal-wood design also
offers advantages and increased
club head speed
through the ball.
The narrow hosel and aerodynamic
design minimize air resistance,
generating greater
club head speed.
The consistent quality of--
CRAWLEY: May be true, may not.
[END PLAYBACK]
Now, why is it interesting
to talk with students
about such things?
Well, we actually use,
through design or accident,
the discussion of sporting
goods throughout almost
the entire curriculum.
There are several of us who
teach freshmen seminars.
Freshmen seminars are
a process now at MIT,
if you don't quite remember
them, where every freshman is
assigned to a faculty advisor
mentor who advises them
through the freshmen year
before they designate a course
but also teaches them a seminar.
I teach one on
sporting good design,
and I use it to teach students
the business of engineering,
which is making products that
make people's lives better--
in this case, sporting goods--
because students can get
their hands around a sporting
good, a piece of
sporting equipment.
They can understand it.
I also subtlely use it to show
the value of Freshman Physics.
Freshman Physics is in one
of those big lecture halls,
and you're not quite
sure what's going on.
So, for example, I show them the
video that you just saw there,
and I let them listen
to the claims that
are made about that golf club.
There were three claims.
Let's see if we can
remember what they are.
They were that perimeter
weighting the head of the club
increases its moment
of inertia, and it
causes the ball to go straighter
with an off-center hit.
True or false?
False.
I'd like to see you and revoke
your 801 grade after the--
more or less true.
More or less true.
If you work out the
dynamics, if you
have a high moment
of inertia club head,
and you hit off-center,
it's less likely to twist
during the time of impact.
A low CG, low center
of gravity, causes
the club to strike the
ball more consistently
and drive it farther,
was the claim.
True or false?
There is no model of
the dynamics of a club
that I can construct that
would cause that to be true.
And thirdly, making
the head aerodynamic
increases the head velocity
at the time of ball impact.
True or false?
Hmm.
How many people think false?
How many people think true?
Well, it sort of
depends, is the answer.
[LAUGHTER]
Let me ask you a
simpler question, which
I ask my freshman.
What's the optimum head
mass for a golf club?
Fix the mass of the ball.
What's the optimum head mass
of the head of the club?
All the mass is in the head,
by the way, for all practical.
Purposes.
You can't exceed a
certain amount, according
to the rules of golf, I think.
That's right.
Thank you.
There's the lawyer.
[LAUGHTER]
And this stresses
an important point,
which is that regulation comes
into sports, just as it does
into aircraft and spacecraft.
So in fact, you can't
exceed the head that's
listed in the rules of golf.
But aside from that, would you
rather make it lower or higher?
Well, it depends on your
model of the human kinematics,
really.
If you model the
body as something
that can produce a
constant velocity,
you'll want to make it higher.
If you model the
body as something
that produces a
torque, which has
to accelerate the
head of the club,
you'll want to make it lower.
So are you a torque source
or a velocity source
when you swing your club?
Well, I'll let you
think about that.
But lastly, and certainly,
letting students
think about sporting
goods like letting
them think about
anything, In fact, is
an outlet for their
creative instincts.
Let me show you the final
assignment in my freshman
seminar last fall, which
was to design a new sport.
Let's forget about
a new tennis racket.
Let's design a whole
new sport, right?
This was the idea
that came up with.
First, they said the
fastest growing sport
amongst our generation
is lacrosse.
I didn't know that.
But it indicated
to me that I had
taught them to think about
market factors, which
was a valuable thing to learn.
Seems like an obvious
lesson if you ever
tried to sell anything, but not
if you're a freshman, perhaps.
Then they observed that lacrosse
sticks are hard to use and hard
to learn to use, so they
redesigned the lacrosse stick
using 801 Freshman Physics.
That made me happy.
But then they observed
that essentially, sports
are a way to represent
on a small field warfare,
and warfare is tactical, and you
push people forward and back.
And essentially, all sports,
except for baseball and cricket
and a few others--
certainly all field sports--
involve the dynamics of
pushing forward on the offense
and retreating on the defense.
And they said, what would
happen if we changed that?
What would happen if we
said that Team A defends
this goal and this
goal, and Team B defends
this goal and this goal?
[LAUGHTER]
So now, a ball in
the middle here--
if it pops out
that way, you have
to run back and be on defense.
But if it pops out
that way, you also
have to run back
and be on defense.
Sort of an interesting idea.
The sort of things
that MIT students are
likely to come up with if you
just say, invent something.
So there's a pedagogic
value in our education
to talking about the
design of things,
letting students build
things, whether they're
sporting goods or spacecraft.
The first is, and
this may seem a little
obvious to all of the people in
the room except the faculty--
[LAUGHTER]
--that the conception, design,
implementation, and operation
of things which serve humanity
is the business of engineering.
And once in a while, we
should say that to students.
Mixed in amongst the
discussion of theory
and the quest for
cutting-edge research,
we should signal
them to the fact
that it's OK to really build
things and help people.
If you are trying to construct
a pedagogic structure
for an Aero-Astro
curriculum, you
would then say, OK, let's have
students build some spacecraft.
Possible, but not
really accessible
at the undergraduate level.
Let's have them
build some aircraft.
Possible, but not really
expectable in the scope
of a semester subject.
So what could you
have them build
in the course of a semester
subject, which would conceive,
design, implement, and
operate, incorporate
the technologies of aerospace?
A piece of sporting good
equipment is not a bad idea.
So sports give us
a ready application
centered on the same disciplines
that we use in aerospace.
The next piece of video
is going to show you
another thing that we do
in the sophomore year--
freshman and sophomore year.
It isn't possible
to have students--
I'm sorry freshman year.
It isn't possible to have
students build an airplane,
but you can have them build
a blimp in a semester.
And this is a--
coming right into focus now--
subject taught by one of my
colleagues, David Newman.
And it's the second-term
freshman subject,
and at the end of the semester,
they design and build a blimp.
This is a
radio-controlled blimp.
It looks like someone's holding
it, but in fact, they aren't.
They're just sort
of standing by it.
Blimps move slow.
They're relatively simple.
They produce lift
with buoyancy, so you
don't have to know much
about aerodynamics.
And this may in fact be the
next NCAA sport, you see.
[LAUGHTER]
The students really enjoy this,
and we enjoy watching them.
Too.
And taking after our
colleague Woodie Flowers,
we actually let them compete.
That's it for that video.
When they're sophomores,
we have an approach
called Unified
Engineering, which
takes four subjects
in the sophomore year
and mashes them all
together, so they
are educated in an
integrative environment where
they learn that the structures
person has to know what
the fluids person is doing.
They all have to be organized
by the control person.
There's some
thermodynamics involved,
and they do problems that are
called systems problems, which
cause them to bring together
all of these aspects
and either do an
integrative analysis
or an integrative design.
Now, one of my
colleagues, Steve Hall,
decided that an interesting
integrative design
project this past spring would
be to have them build a glider.
A glider is actually not a bad
thing for sophomores to build.
It has aerodynamics, but
it doesn't have propulsion.
It's relatively easy to
test, and he got the idea
by some collaborative
interaction of actually making
contact with a toy
company, Hasbro,
the manufacturer of Nerf,
and using the sophomore class
to design the replacement
for this, the Nerf airplane.
So the Hasbro guys came and
talked about the market.
The toy business is
segmented in a certain way,
and the market size is
so much, and so forth.
They talked about the
design requirements,
and the subtle one
for this toy is
it has to be enjoyable by
four or five-year-olds,
who will throw it like this.
I am a rated pilot, so it's OK.
[LAUGHTER]
But it has to also be
enjoyable by 10-year-olds,
who will throw it like this.
And this toy actually fails
because it trims nose up
in steady-state flight, so
that when you throw it hard,
it pitches up and stalls.
There are regulations.
Sure, there's no regulations
on toys, right, in America.
[LAUGHTER]
It's probably easier to satisfy
the federal airworthiness
regulations than the
toy safety regulations.
So they were actually
presented with a book
of essentially the
regulations of building toys.
Then they had to come
up with a concept.
They had to do the aerodynamic
analysis and the stress
analysis, and they had to make
a design for manufacturability,
another innovative concept
to get across to students.
And in fact, this is
a very low-cost toy.
It's stamped out
of pieces of foam.
So if you could get it
out of one piece of foam,
that was the best.
If you could get it out
of two pieces of foam,
that was better, and so forth.
And then finally, we had
a set of flight tests.
The students were
captivated by this project.
The instructors said that they
absorb this stuff that we teach
them in the second
semester like sponges,
compared to semesters when we
didn't do a project like this
because, of course,
while they were
learning about flight dynamics,
they were designing a glider.
While they were
learning about beams,
they were doing the
analysis of a wing.
The more of that
we can do at MIT,
the happier our
students will be.
We have an exercise in the
junior and senior years
where teams of
students work together
to identify a research
project and then
execute it over the
course of two semesters.
They have to design
the experiment,
and they have to take data.
It's not sufficient
to, for example,
write a computer program.
There has to be an experiment.
There has to be
data produced which
they have to be able to analyze
and compare with a model,
and then, of
course, they report.
We use this as a vehicle for
a lot of communication skills,
in particular.
We let the students,
by and large,
choose their own projects.
And not surprisingly,
a lot of them
come up with sporting goods.
This is one project which
is, of course, a plaster
cast of a hand, which was
used by a team of students
to determine the
aerodynamic drag on a hand
because, of course, they
were competitive swimmers.
And the question that rages
in the swimming community
is do you get the maximum
efficiency by having your hand
like this or like this?
Is it better to form a little
more projected plan form
or to cup it?
So they actually
did the aerodynamic
at the right Reynolds number
of two plaster casts of hands
to see which had the
higher drag coefficient.
And the answer is--
I don't quite remember,
unfortunately.
[LAUGHTER]
But the MIT swim team
has been winning.
So just in case there are any
alumna of other universities
here, we don't want
to give up any--
back to golf clubs,
you of course,
recognize this as your
Saturday afternoon hobby.
Usually, it's instrumented
about like this, right?
This is given to us
kindly by Calloway.
We've done quite a few
tests on golf club dynamics.
I actually use this in
my freshman seminar,
and I've had a few
undergraduate projects.
The real questions are things
like does anything matter?
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
If you went out to the
average Saturday golfer
and gave him a driver and told
him that Tiger Woods had just
won with this one, he or she
would probably drive it farther
because there's some interesting
psychophysiological feedback
that occurs in golf.
If you think you're going to hit
the ball well, you usually do.
The average drive
distance on the Pro Tour
over the last decade
has gone up five yards.
So every time you see
a Saturday afternoon ad
that says our driver
drives 20 yards farther--
good marketing.
But the fact of the
matter is that the ball
is in contact with the head of
a club for a half a millisecond,
and there's not an
awful lot you can
do to anything to change the
events in a half a millisecond.
There are some quasistatic
effects that you actually
get to teach them about
centrifugal destiffening,
as you bring the club down
at 100 feet per second,
and the club bends.
That's a real effect.
So we play around
with golf clubs.
Tennis is a big one.
These are two experimental
tennis rackets.
This is my colleague, Ramnath.
This one-- I don't know
if you can hear it,
hear that-- has powder in it.
So this is to
provide extra damping
when you impact the ball, which
is thought to reduce the tennis
elbow problem.
And this one has fluid, which
zings around in the outside.
There's actually a
fluid tube in here,
which is thought,
according to Ram,
somehow to increase the
actual delivered power because
of variable geometry.
Students do experiments in this.
We actually have
a test facility,
if you want to call it that,
where we do measurements on--
if I pull this, I'm
almost certainly
going to take the skin off
of this part of my arm.
I used to do that in
summer camp all the time,
but they weren't this strong.
The compound bow-- perhaps
one of the oldest pieces
of technology on the planet.
Found in the tomb of King
Tut was something called
a compound bow, where there
were three types of materials
used to build up
the bow, starting
from the hardest on the
center line, which I think
was ivory, to wood, to leather.
The ancient Egyptians
understood that by varying
the modulus of elasticity
of the material
away from the neutral
axis, an archer
could store more strain
energy in the bow
and shoot the arrow farther.
Well, we're still doing
that, except now, they're
advanced composite graphite
epoxy and all sorts of bells
and whistles.
This one, again, is
heavily strain-guaged
to understand the strain energy
distribution during launch.
The students love
to do these things.
We find consistently that the
projects the students initiate
are significantly more
successful than the ones
that the professors say, well,
let's test this new widget.
At MIT, we have a
tradition of actually doing
things in addition to
educating students.
And this is just a list of some
of the things in the sporting
good business that my
colleagues and I have done
over the last decade or so.
If you go down a ski slope
now, you're about three times
less likely to injure yourself
through an ankle or leg break
than you would
have been a decade
or so ago, thanks to the ASTM
ski binding regulations set
by the ASTM Snow
Skiing Committee
formerly chaired by Larry
Young, one of my colleagues.
It's reduced the ski
binding-related injuries
from six per 1,000 skier days
to two per 1,000 skier days.
Pretty significant benefit.
JAR22 is Joint
Airworthiness Requirements,
a European standard
for powerless aircraft,
including gliders.
It used to be thought
that you could not
protect a pilot in a
high-performance glider
from a crash impact, a
nose-down crash impact.
And actually, a
student of mine was
killed in one of such
impacts, which caused me
and one of my colleagues
Hansman to consider whether this
was really the case.
We had a set of students over
several years build 1/4-scale
scale models and crash them
in our laboratory and prove
to the world that you can,
in fact, protect a glider,
a pilot, as well as any
pilot in any aircraft.
And as a result, the
airworthiness requirements
were changed to require
such protection.
On a little lighter note,
one of my other colleagues,
Ramnath, has established the
standards for the Pro Tennis
Tour line-calling machines.
As you're maybe aware,
increasingly in pro tennis,
the lines are called by
machine, not by human eye.
And we haven't actually
invented one of the machines,
but we've been involved
in the regulation of what
the specification of the
line-calling machines are.
Now these three form
a pattern, which
is that they put us
in a research role
for the regulatory agency.
Skis, airplanes, pro tennis--
and that's something
that I think
is appropriate for MIT,
as an organization, to do.
We have also been involved
in for-profit ventures--
that is to say,
individuals amongst us.
I don't know if you
can see this well.
But this is a softball bat.
By the way, softball
is the big market.
Nobody plays pro baseball
with a wooden bat.
Everyone plays Saturday
afternoon softball and Little
League with metal bats.
And this is a dimpled bat,
dimpled just like a golf ball,
so that when you
swing, it'll go faster,
provided of course that you
model the human as a velocity
source and not as
a torque source.
Now, what I'm very
proud of in this ball,
and you can't see this,
so I'll read it to you--
is that it says
Power Stick, which
is sort of good marketing.
And it actually says on
here delayed boundary layer
separation.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, I'm not sure who they
think out there in America
is going to understand that.
[LAUGHTER]
But I'm particularly proud
that something came out
of the Aero department
that has on the side of it,
delayed boundary
layer separation.
Because it might actually
cause some kid out
there someplace to ask
his dad, as they're
getting the ice cream
after the baseball game--
Dad, what's a boundary layer?
[LAUGHTER]
The best-selling ski in
America, the K2 Four,
has a brain inside the ski,
done by a colleague of mine,
Haygood, who has
the original idea
and manufactured by another
former student of mine,
Lazarus, at a
company called ACX.
The ski uses new technology.
This a little point-of-purchase
sticker, which
is on the ski when you buy it.
This ski uses new
technology developed
by MIT-trained engineers.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
Now we're really making an
impact in America, you see.
Now, this ski really works.
You see, what happens is you
saw the video of the vibration
of the ski on the snow.
And in fact, the average height
of the ski off the snow surface
is almost a centimeter.
If you reduce the
vibration amplitude
by increasing the damping
or dissipation in the ski,
it vibrates less,
and more of the ski
is in contact with the surface,
so you can really plant an edge
and turn on it.
And that's done by a little
piezoelectric material patch
here, which takes the energy
from mechanical energy
into electrical energy,
and then dissipates it
in a resistor, which is in here.
But now, the really
cool thing is
that when you're in the
showroom, and you whack it,
there's a little LED
that lights up there.
[LAUGHTER]
Now we know that's going
to help your skiing.
[LAUGHTER]
There are three great
traditions at MIT--
hacks, sports, and technology.
So if you can find something
that combines all three
of these, boy,
you've got a winner.
And we have these things from
time to time in the department
that we just call special
projects, which are almost
always student-initiated.
The successful ones are almost
always student-initiated
that combine these aspects of
hacks, sports, and technology.
They're an outlet for
creativity and competitiveness.
They're usually long-duration.
They're almost always voluntary.
The students do it nights
and weekends and vacations
and summers, and I
think that they really
add a tremendous amount
to the educational value
of the students.
We have a couple of slides of
the history of some of these.
I built one of these when I
was an undergraduate in MIT.
And they're of the flavor of--
oh, thank you.
They are of the flavor of
human-powered airplanes.
We've built other
things, but I'll
show you the human-powered
airplane family.
This was the first one, called
the biplane ultralight research
device, BIRD, which was a
two-pedaler biplane intended
to fly for the
first Kramer Prize,
which was to fly a mile
around a figure-eight pylon.
The pylons were
half a mile apart.
And there's the propeller.
And the pedalers
would sit there,
and it flies that
way, by the way.
And there's a young future
ahead of the Aero department
right there, with more hair.
This one crashed.
Next slide.
[LAUGHTER]
Here IS the next
one in the family.
This is called Crystallis,
also a biplane.
Now it flies like a
conventional airplane.
It was built by some
colleagues of mine,
including Mark
Drela, John Langford,
who now runs Aurora Flight.
This was a very good trainer,
and it was also built by us
to compete with Paul McCreadie
in the cross-English Channel
competition, which Paul beat us.
But this would have
flown Dover to Calais.
Next slide.
This is Monarch.
There's the single pilot
flying in that direction.
This was built by essentially
the same team of students
from the last airplane.
And this was designed to
win the third Kramer Prize
competition of the
Royal Aeronautical
Society, which was for speed,
for human-powered speed flight.
And the first winner would be
for the first team that flew
more than 20 miles an hour.
And this plane achieved that,
flying out at Hanscom Airfield.
So this was our first win
in the human-powered flight.
Now you have to think
for just a second,
and I think the
next slide will show
this, what it really takes--
oops.
Could you go back one slide?
Fig leaves is what it takes.
[LAUGHTER]
--what it takes for a group of
students to build one of these.
I mean, first, they have to
decide they want to do it.
This is a several-year effort.
They have to decide
they want to do it,
and they know they're
going to do it
nights and weekends and holidays
and vacations and so forth.
They have to design the plane.
They have to raise money to
build it within the MIT system.
Then they have to find the space
to build it, one of the most
daunting tasks at MIT.
Then they have to actually
engage in the construction,
go out to the flight
facility in Bedford,
put the whole thing
together, flight test it.
And you flight test
human-powered airplanes,
by the way, when the winds are
very low, early in the morning.
And then, of course,
coordinate the whole team.
It's really a marvelous
effort, and the students
who participate in projects
like this in any department
derive a tremendous
benefit from the education.
Well, after we had won the
human-powered speed prize,
there was only one grand
challenge left-- next slide--
which was to reproduce the
mythical flight of Daedalus.
And Daedalus, of course,
was a real person.
He was an engineer in the
court of the King of Athens,
who fled to Crete, where he
got in trouble with the king
there and fled again.
And in one of those flights, he
is said to actually have flown.
Icarus, by the way, was added
by the Romans to the myth.
Daedalus is a real person.
He is credited with inventing
the saw and the lathe,
among other things.
Icarus was added by the Romans
to make the moral of the story,
listen to your father.
[LAUGHTER]
So if I could have
the last video now--
this team of students
created this airplane.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Everyone who has witnessed
the flight of the Monarch
agrees it is truly
a thrilling sight
and almost takes you back
to the days of early flight
with Wilbur and Orville Wright.
And the MIT students
tell us they fulfilled
all the requirements,
followed all the rules,
and they're just waiting--
CRAWLEY: This is Daedalus taking
off for an airport in Crete.
This is Professor Musolari
in the chase boat.
The flight of Daedalus--
there is no agreement amongst
the historians and mythologies
about which two islands
he flew between.
So we flew from Crete,
the capital of Knossos,
to the island of
Santorini, which
is agreed to be amongst one
of the probable courses.
It's about a three-hour flight.
It's about 80 miles.
We had four pilots in training--
I believe four or five
pilots in training-- one
of whom was a Greek
Olympic bicycle athlete.
They were all
Olympic-caliber bicyclists.
And they rotated, just like
the Mercury astronauts.
And on the morning of the
actual good conditions,
it turned out that it was the
Greeks day, which made everyone
in Greece very happy,
that a Greek man actually
got the flight.
So we take off from
Crete, in the background
there, at a Greek
military installation.
Why don't you just turn up
the volume enough so the--
- It's better than perfect.
My pulse now goes
to 30s, upper 30s.
CRAWLEY: Among other things,
we invented human fuel
in the course of this project.
- The Greek Navy, Coast
Guard, and Air Force are on--
CRAWLEY: The pilot actually
got dribbled to him
a specially-prepared
solution of sugars.
and such carbohydrates
so that he can basically
suck human fuel.
If you could do
that in a marathon,
you'd never hit the wall.
- The only concern is that
it will all be over too soon.
CRAWLEY: On the actual
day of the flight,
there was a
considerable tailwind.
So although we were only
flying about 15 knots,
the speed over the ground or
over the bottom of the ocean
was about 20 knots.
- The only landmarks now are
the world records falling one
by one.
First down is the Gossamer
Albatross straight-line record
of 22 miles.
CRAWLEY: That was the
cross-channel flight.
- Then, it's the Light
Eagle's absolute distance
mark at 37 miles.
CRAWLEY: Which was
one of our planes.
- Finally, the Gossamer
Albatross duration
record at two hours
and 49 minutes.
CRAWLEY: That was the
cross-channel flight.
- But the records have
become almost a footnote
to the experience.
The greater
satisfaction now comes
from the realization
of a dream--
a modern mythical creature,
half man, half machine,
living out the earliest
fantasy of flight.
Almost four hours
into the journey,
Daedalus approaches its final
goal, the island of Santorini.
- OK.
Santorini Beach.
This is Command Boat.
We're going to want to get
ready to lay the smoke for us.
- It's just over those boats.
- I see it.
- The flight has been
flawless, almost routine.
Canellos could probably
keep going for hours,
but the gods are not going to
let the mortals off so easily.
The wind has suddenly picked up.
- Steve, the smoke
is coming out.
- Canellos we'll have to
come in parallel to the beach
for an upwind landing.
- OK, let's get the beach
clear, beach people.
And Canellos, I want 20
degrees to the right.
Give me a good right turn.
I want to give
you plenty of room
to approach that landing site.
Over.
- OK, don't worry.
- I never worry.
OK, you look good now.
[INDISTINCT CHATTER]
OK, we've got a
big headwind here.
We're barely make
it any way at all.
Canellos, that looks good.
Maintain this heading.
There are people running
on the beach now.
- I think there is
a lot of people.
- OK, well don't
worry about that.
We're going to land
where they aren't.
- Caught in the strong
headwind, Canellos
is having trouble
approaching the beach.
- OK, maintain that heading.
CRAWLEY: So you can see he's
about 30 yards from Santorini.
- OK, you're looking
good, Canellos.
A little bit of a
right-hand correction.
A little bit of
Be easy-- uh oh.
Uh oh.
- A gust of wind snapped the
tail boom and then the wing,
turning a Daedelus into Icarus.
CRAWLEY: Listen to your dad.
- The first thought is for
the safety of Canellos.
CRAWLEY: You can
cut the video there.
Thanks.
[END PLAYBACK]
I was not on the
beach that morning.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
That applause, of
course, is for the team
of students and
faculty who did that,
of which I was not a member.
But I will accept
it on their behalf.
I was not there that
morning, but I'm
told by John Langford, who was
the project leader, that if you
don't believe in
the gods of Olympus,
that their influence that
day was just palpable.
They were going to let
these mortals get so far.
[LAUGHTER]
And then they were just going
to reach down at the last second
and crush that little airplane.
Well, in conclusion,
Barton Rogers
said some interesting things--
that we should
provide an education
relevant to an
industrializing nation.
Maybe now, we'd say it's an
industrialized or maybe even
post-industrial nation.
That our education should
be pragmatic and practical,
that we should have
teaching coupled
with hands-on education, and
that technical education is
an appropriate basis for
a professional education
at the undergraduate level.
That is the founding
dream of the Institute.
I think that the more
we keep that in mind,
and the more we keep pushing
ourselves towards that goal,
the better job we do for
our students and our future.
But Barton Rogers never
said it couldn't be fun.
That was something
that sort of got
added in the interpretation
over the years.
So we try and keep
it fun, as well.
And in fact, we think
it's so much fun
that we've decided to create a
center for sports engineering
here at MIT.
And partly inspired by
preparing for this talk,
we pulled together
all of the faculty
who were involved in this and
who had done these things,
and we said, boy, there's
really something here.
So we've put together a
cooperative group of people
from Aero-Astro, Warren
Seering's NSF Center
for Innovation and
Product Development,
and the Department of Athletics,
who are thrilled by this,
by the way, because
now they have
some access into the
intellectual life
of the Institute.
[LAUGHTER]
And our goal is to create
new sports, new products,
and new standards for sports.
We're going to start
this in the fall of '97
with some freshmen
seminars, and this activity
is going to be home-based
and the Wright brothers' wind
tunnel, which is a big enough
wind tunnel to stand bicyclists
and tennis players up
and actually measure
their aerodynamics.
So there is, in some senses,
a long-standing legacy
of this presentation
this morning.
Well, I enjoyed
putting this together.
[APPLAUSE]
And I have the honor of being
followed here on the podium
this morning by one of my
truly esteemed colleagues,
who has, in fact,
been the guy who
has shown many of us
the way to incorporate
design and engineering into
the undergraduate curriculum.
Professor Woodie Flowers.
FLOWERS: Thank you, sir.
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHTER]
Good morning.
More about that later.
It's great to be here.
Welcome back.
I've seen some very young
people in the audience,
so we probably should do a duel.
There's some people
here for the first time.
I'm really glad you could come.
It's a very, very
special event when
you get a thousand MIT alums and
their family members in a room.
It's impressive.
There is a lot of
power here today.
In fact, you're a wonderfully
intimidating audience,
and I'm looking forward
to talking to you.
The opportunity cost of
this meeting is really high,
so I will try to make
it worth your while.
Now, the title of my talk
was a bit presumptuous,
but the real title wouldn't fit.
The words that I've
added at the top
are to make it a
little more humble.
I don't know about hard fun, but
I think there are some things.
I think that you guys
really know quite a lot.
Dave, if you could
get on focus--
you can read that list.
The examples are going
to be five examples--
I will warn you,
I'm going to go fast
because I want you to
get to lunch on time.
I have 10 and 1/2 minutes of
video and about 100 slides,
so heads up.
But I will get you there.
So what is hard fun?
Well, I don't know.
There are lots of
ways to interpret it.
Several people have talked
about it this morning.
This is hard fun for me.
You're, as I said, an
intimidating audience,
so it was really hard
to think about what
I might say to you
that might represent
a reasonably cohesive message.
So I think that hard fun lines
at the intersection of learning
and hard work and some fun,
and I think you guys probably
really understand that.
And I think Vladimir was right--
you do have to have both,
and you do have to mix them.
But I think this quote probably
talks more directly to you
guys than the other.
You can't make people happy
by taking away the things that
make them unhappy.
You have spent your
careers doing hard fun
and using hard fun to obtain
various kinds of satisfaction,
some of them very transient or
orgasmic, and some of them long
and subtle things
that develop that have
to do with satisfaction
with the life
of your family and your career.
But you have engaged in lots
of hard fun, so I defer to you.
You probably know
more about it than me.
In the talk, I'm going to make
reference to several authors.
I'm going to cop out
and talk about maybe
what some other people might
have said about the topic.
And it's appropriate
to start with seasons.
For the ladies in the audience,
you can think passages.
But I'm reminded of the
infamous survey which
discovered that MIT alums about
five years out think, boy, I
wish I'd learned calculus
and physics a little better.
And about 15 years
out they say, ah,
if I'd just gotten the
economics and management
stuff down a little better.
And then about 20
or 30 years later,
they say, boy, if I
just studied philosophy.
I think I have shifted.
I'm kind of on schedule,
and I'm changing.
This process started
for me in about 1970.
I don't know exactly when
this picture was taken.
My hair was a little
denser at that point
and a little more plentiful.
But if I were beginning
this talk then,
I would have talked more about
the details of the machines
and the process.
But I want to pull back today
and talk in a more general way.
Now, as I said, I don't
think we know the answers,
but we have learned
a few things,
and I'd like to give
you some examples.
I'm going to stick to
things that I know about
because I was directly involved
with them and therefore
maybe a little safer
in making comments.
First, I'd like to show you a
video about the 2.70 contest.
It is a whole bunch of
students, a kit of materials,
and for the most part, it's
a sophomore-level course.
For the most part, they're
designing and building
something for the first
time in their life.
So if we could have the
first video, please.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Christina's deadly
wedge is a perfect example
of the fast and low
design strategy.
- You got it.
You got it.
Oh yeah.
- She notches yet another
convincing victory,
as more and more
opponents bit the dust.
FLOWERS: This is a three-minute
clip from the program Discover.
- --I had my thing
right underneath them,
and you couldn't
get into the area.
- This power shovel machine
is also moving up fast.
Tony chose a good design
and built it well.
- I took a lot of time.
It took me a long
time, but I thought
that I think a lot of
care in what I built.
- Tony deploys his
shovel and moves steadily
toward the summit.
He rocks the joystick
confidently and gets the shovel
under the other machine.
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
It's another win
for Tony, and he
advances toward the semifinal
round of the competition.
Every battle now
is a fierce one,
and the losers go out in style.
[AUDIENCE CHEERING AND LAUGHING]
- There's really only one
person I'm really scared now,
and I think I have to go
against her next, too.
- Christina and her wedge
machine Kee's low rider
in the first semifinal match.
They both hope to
plant their ping pong
balls on the mountain top,
but Christina is faster.
Her wedge gets under
Kee's defenses,
and gravity does the rest.
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
- She has the best car here.
She's going to win, no problem.
- Now it's Bob with an arm
machine up against Tony
in the other semifinal.
Tony takes off confidently
and lowers the shovel.
Bob rolls up to
meet him, but Tony
has something in reserve,
a design that combines
the best of both strategies.
He raises a short, stubby
arm, backs into the zone,
and pulls off another win.
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
And so Tony lines up against
Christina in the final battle.
- Ready.
Get set.
Go.
- Christina races toward
the top in pursuit
of another quick victory,
but Tony digs in and waits
for her to release her ball.
The power shovel
gets under her wedge.
She's almost upended.
Tony goes to work on the
defenseless ping pong ball.
- Back up.
Back up.
Now back up.
Back up again.
- To heighten the victory, Tony
fires his arm, and he wins.
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
FLOWERS: Remember all of that.
There will be a quiz later.
I'd like to get on
with another example
and tell you a little bit about
an organization called FIRST,
which is founded by a
wonderfully crazy, wild,
and successful man, an
extremely intelligent man named
Dean Kamen.
FIRST has been
around for six years.
Now, the design competition part
of it started just after Dean
and I met, and it's a little
bit like 2,70 on steroids.
The recent competition
involved 155 teams.
There was a regional in
Chicago, in New Hampshire,
and in New Jersey, and then
the Nationals were at Epcot.
We're looking forward to a very,
very big year this coming year.
In the last year, President
Best was kind enough
to sponsor the MIT team.
If you really love
me, during this video,
you will write down
that 800 number--
in particular, if you're
involved with a company
that might be
interested in working
with MIT and a high school
in order to do this.
The video that I
want you to see now
is a three-minute
rap show that was
part of the introduction
to the awards ceremony
at the recent finals
at Epcot in Florida.
So if we can start
the second video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[UPBEAT ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
That's Dean Kamen.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
So that was a--
unless something
unexpected happens,
you will all get a
chance to see some
of the stories associated with
FIRST in the fall or winter.
Sorry I can't say
more about that,
but I think there's
a good chance
that lots of folks in the
country will know about it.
Now, the other thing
I'd like to show you
is a quick video clip which was
very personal to me, if we can
start the next video, please.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- At GTE, the power is on.
- Hi, my name's Woodie Flowers.
I know that sounds like the
name of a cartoon character,
but it's easy to remember, and
it's always served me well.
I'm actually a professor at
MIT with a lot of curiosity
about the world around
me and how it works,
which is why I'm standing
here dressed like a skydiver.
This new series is
going to explore
the frontiers of
science, and I'm
going to get to go
along for the ride.
I'm going to ask some questions,
maybe answer a few, poke fun
occasionally, and test some
of the frontiers myself, which
brings me back to
the skydiving outfit.
I've always wondered
what it would
be like to jump out of a plane.
So I'm going to find out.
[TRIUMPHANT MUSIC]
[PLANE ENGINE RUNNING]
- Make sure your head's
up, nice and high.
Hard arch.
- It's fantastic.
Oh, I hope you guys can hear me.
- All right.
Give me a left turn, Woodie.
Give me a left turn.
- OK.
- Left turn, left
turn, left turn.
Stop, left turn.
- That was a nice, swift turn.
This is a 3D sportscard.
Here I come.
- Three, two, one.
Clear.
All right, great.
[END PLAYBACK]
FLOWERS: There will be a
quiz on that, too, later.
So those are three examples.
Let me move on to some more.
We talk a little bit about
our senior Product Engineering
course and what we do there.
We're really mean
to the students.
In order to force some
of the issues that
are very important
to engineering
teamwork and projects, we
give them the problem too big
in a time too short
and groups too large
and a budget too small--
very close simulation
to the stuff
that Steve talked about earlier.
Now the students' reaction
is, as you might expect,
but they've really been
quite fantastic in the past.
They start the process
with more meetings
than they've ever
had in their lives,
and they have to
learn about meetings.
And then they get into
doing some calculations
and using their
engineering science,
and they find themselves
poring over catalogs
and finding out that
dealers and that vendors
don't deliver when they
said they were going to.
The learn a lot of lessons
about simple tools.
They use some fairly
more elegant tools.
They use some modern
processes in doing
this wonderful job
of building mock-ups
and then, finally, a prototype.
And they work together.
They help each other.
They work very intensely.
A team of 25 students who are
taking several other courses
at the same time have to learn
to break the problem up, trust
one another, and get it done.
So there is an enormous
amount of tension associated
with making this happen.
But we've been doing
it for six years now,
and every time, the
students have finished
with a machine or a
device that met spec,
was on time, and under budget.
That's really quite amazing.
Now they make a mess in the
process, but at the end of it,
they have some quite
remarkable things.
From last fall,
for example, this
was a battery-operated
boogie board
for kids, a little
battery-operated surfboard,
essentially, a toy.
Here was an industrial
scooter for use inside plants.
It had a nice
extendable cargo deck.
One of the machines was the
most powerful and fast sea sled
for wreck divers, and
a great video of it
outrunning the fastest
sled on the market today.
And there was a
battery-operated wheelbarrow,
which they aimed at
the domestic market
and discovered that there were
lots of construction sites
where, inside buildings, you
couldn't use gasoline engines,
and that was a very
good idea, as well.
There was a very delightful
design of a confined space
rescue system.
That serpentine capstone that
you see there gripped the rope
and would allow a battery
pack to lift someone out
of a well or some of the other
confined space rescue areas.
So that was celebrated by
the Cambridge Rescue Team.
And the scooter
that you just saw
is a commuter scooter
that allows one to fold it
down and take off in it.
As you see, it works quite well,
and it's really a lot of fun.
Now, they then at the
end of this process
give very professional
presentations
in which they present
their business plan,
they present their
knowledge of the market,
and they do that in front
of a critical audience
and get some real
feedback about what
people think of their ideas.
We think that that
kind of whole process
is very, very important.
Now, they also experience a
kind of bonding and unity.
At the end of this
whole thing, there's
a lot of shared feeling of
relief, among other things.
But several years
ago, for instance,
when we did a battery-operated
riding lawnmowers,
all the teams were anxious to
gather out in the Great Court.
In fact, the entire
course gathered out
in the Great Court.
They'd been through something
that pulls them all together,
and it had to do with pushing
the envelope as far as it would
tolerate without tearing it.
So it's hard fun.
Let me talk a little bit
about a graduate design course
that Professor David
Wallace and I teach.
Most of the focus is on
aesthetics and human factors.
We tell them this is a
course about process.
And process is really
first, but then we
say we lie-- it's about
good products, too.
So the students, even
though many of them
have never had a
drafting course,
even do a very good job of
raising the bar for one another
and doing renderings,
for example,
that look quite good to
industrial designers.
They're not going to take an
industrial designer's job,
but they've done a lot
about communicating
their ideas to other people--
a very sophisticated move
forward in a very short time.
They then make sketch
models out of foam,
and they all assemble
together, and each person
has three sketch models.
And they present them,
and what they then do
is exchange ideas
among one another
about the sketch models.
And that particular exchange
is very rich in communication.
It's rich in critique.
Engineers don't generally want
to have anyone criticizing
their ideas, but
we try to get them
to understand that critique
is not criticizing.
It's helping to
develop a better idea.
So they do a fantastic job
of helping one another,
working together, and,
in fact, almost always,
their design evolves in some
way during that process.
Now, at the end of
that, they get down
to the hard business of
making the real visual model,
and they spend a lot of
time in the lab together.
They get to know each
other very, very well,
and they see one
another doing things,
and they all kind of
do it better and better
because of that.
And as that process
moves through,
all of the stuff that
each student does
is done with their own hands.
And they end up with a
very proud attachment
to what they've done.
Then, they have created
these nice visual models.
This was a series that had
to do with a personal digital
assistant for
traffic and weather,
and the ideas are quite diverse.
And it's really great to see
the range and creativity.
Some of the devices are
very, very convincing.
They looked like
real prototypes.
What they then do--
if could have the
next tray, please--
is we gather a very substantial
audience for them, a jury.
This last semester,
there were 35 students.
We had 40 jurors.
And the students present
their ideas to the jury,
and the jury includes
people like Bill Mitchell,
Dean of Architecture,
and representatives
of most of the design
firms in the Boston area.
So they get real pros
to look over their work,
give them feedback, fill
out forms, exchange ideas
with them, and it's done with
a great deal of enthusiasm,
and the students really
get a lot out of it,
and they are very anxious
to see what the people said.
One of the nice things
is is that puts us
in a position of being the
coach rather than the evaluator.
This last semester was
wearable computers.
One of the models, a
quite elegantly done model
by Tom Almi.
He here is getting some feedback
from an industrial designer
from a local firm who had
spent quite a lot of time
on exactly that same problem.
A lot of rich feedback.
So that process is
different than a final exam.
It's very rich in
information back.
So I've given you five examples.
Great.
A lot of good stuff happening,
but what does it mean?
Well, I don't know,
but some thoughts.
One is, for sure, that we
think Einstein is right.
Creativity is a very, very
important part of this process,
and we must overtly charge the
students with being creative.
Warren Seering is right.
The way you get students to
be creative is you assign it.
If you don't make it
part of the process,
it ain't going to happen.
It's the painful part.
It's not the default thing.
It's risky.
It makes your brain hurt.
And it's delightful when we
say please do it, they do it.
If you look at this
series of machines,
they were all in 2.70
a year or so ago,
and they were all done to
accomplish the same task.
Delightful variety in
what they look like-- they
were all effective
in their own ways.
This one had
counter-rotating augers
to screw its way through
the medium of the contest
that year.
Now here is Alex Slocum
with a group of the students
that went off to do the
international version
of the design contest.
Alex has been running the
course for the last three years.
Beforehand, it was Harry West.
Harry did a great
job of creating
the international version--
a wonderful tradition,
it continues to grow.
We think it has some
very powerful lessons.
But the context for
all of these things
is exercising, developing
your creative design skills
and creating a different
self-image of yourself.
You have to be able to trust
your ability to be creative.
A lot of people,
including myself,
think that Scott
Adams will be regarded
as one of the 20th century's
great philosophers.
I think that's probably
right, but here's one example.
Wally and I have come up with
a great new product idea.
Management inspiration alert
in effect, danger, new idea.
Now, here's
Crush-o-Matic, which is
about to splat the
creator of the new idea.
In order to have an
impact on the world
and push creative ideas, you
have to have the courage.
It takes about a dozen your baby
is uglies to get one Eureka.
And so you have to leave
the educational system
fortified enough to take
a beating over and over
and still come back
asking for more.
I still remember this
student's coming into my office
and crying because she didn't
want to take the courses.
She had never built anything.
She hated the whole
idea, and she ended up
feeling so good
about having made
this machine do what she
wanted it to do that she became
a design engineer.
That, I think, is one
of the real victories,
what it's all about.
Another thing that is a facet
of this hard fun activity
is what I've started calling
gracious professionalism.
It's really, really nice to
see students working closely
together, helping one another,
treating the competition
as the celebration
of the learning that
has happened to that
point, which is what it is.
It's not cutthroat competition.
It is a celebration.
The students dress up.
They do it with a
great deal of style,
and it's very, very nice to
see 20-year-old men giving
each other a hug after they
just had a competition.
That's the right
stuff, and we want
very much to keep that alive.
There are lots of stories
about that sort of activity
in the first competition.
I will spare you some of those.
Now, I think Goldman has some
very, very powerful points
in the book Emotional
Intelligence,
and I think it is very, very
much a part of hard fun.
When you push
really hard, to me,
it is very clear that pressure
is a major part of creativity.
We don't do creative
things for the most part,
unless we have to.
It's hard.
We do them when we're running
or doing other things,
but in fact, they
don't just fall out.
So dealing with the pressure
is a very important thing.
I tell the students
that they have
to learn to make friends with
the knot in their stomach
and recognize it as an asset.
I have a knot in
my stomach today.
It's part of life.
It's there.
You learn to use it
rather than block you.
There's another part of
emotional intelligence,
though, that is best illustrated
by a tragic story that
goes with FIRST.
In the early years,
a large company
worked with a school in a very,
very rough part of the town
where the company was located.
And that year, the finals were
in Manchester, New Hampshire.
They came.
President Bush was campaigning.
He came by.
He met the students,
drove their machine.
The students were then in a
gymnasium with several thousand
people cheering, bands playing,
cheerleaders, the whole thing.
It was an amazing celebration.
The linkage that developed
between the high school
students and the
engineers in this company
was just phenomenal.
One of the students got home,
returned to the same old stuff,
committed suicide the next
day, and left a note explaining
that, as far as he could
tell, he had reached the peak,
and it was never going
to be that good again.
So in that particular instance,
many, many alarms went off,
and we have learned
something about re-entry.
If we take people out
of an environment that
has no opportunity and
bury them in opportunity,
we have to be careful about
letting them slip back
into that.
So there are many kinds of
emotional intelligence that
are, I think,
inherent in hard fun.
Forgiveness is another
thing that's very important.
The students have to learn
to trust one another.
They have to, when
someone fails to deliver
their part of
something on time, they
have to forgive them,
recognize what's
the agenda that
has to move ahead,
and get back to the business.
For me, that skydiving
thing was a wonderful piece
of learning for me because
I went out the week before,
and they said you can
go do one if you want
to do one before the shoot.
I said, great.
I've always wanted to do that.
I went out and went through
the training course.
During the dive, you
have to do a whole bunch
of things the instructors
are telling you to do.
You have to look at
their ride, and you
have to read your altimeter.
You have to look at
the person on the left,
look at the person on the right,
and I knew that the next week,
I was going to be asked
to do lines in between.
And you have to go
through that four cycles
before you pull the cord.
The jump master had to keep
me from pulling the wrong cord
because I was thinking about
all these other things.
And when I realized
what had happened,
or what I had almost done wrong,
I was really hard on myself.
And I was going into my first
TV shoot beating myself up
for hours about how can I
have done something so dumb.
I'm going to be there.
There's going to be a
camera plane, camera
in the airplane, camera
on the other guy's helmet.
There's going to be all
this stuff going on,
and I'm not going
do the right thing.
About Thursday of
the week before I
did the jump on
Saturday, I finally
decided, buddy, you've got to
forgive yourself and get on
with it.
And I think that's
one of the lessons.
Robin [? Casserman's ?]
book makes that point very,
very well.
I think it's an important
part of hard fun.
We have to help the students
pull this nice sweep over some
of the difficult parts.
Partway through a
big complex project,
things are going rough.
But after it's
over, it feels good,
and you want to
keep that in mind
and recognize that that's where
you think you want to get.
In thinking about
this, I thought
that the cup of knowledge and
stuff is just much too big.
All we can do is kind of set
the boundary conditions right.
The best we can do is build a
foundation, as in the bricks,
and have people start to
learn about themselves,
learn about nature,
and learn about people.
And I made an arrow pointing
up and then realized
quite accidentally I'd
made an image of a house.
And given that house of
quality is a big deal,
I decided this must be
the house of qualities.
But this is one of the
representations of what
we're trying to do here--
set the boundary conditions
right so that growth happens.
Now learning about
nature is the thing
that we've done well
at MIT for a long time.
That might be what
you call physics.
It's one of the things that you
do have to come to understand,
though, is that she will not
give you a reprieve, even
for a nanosecond.
She sticks to the
rules all the time,
and students, in their
first design project,
are very, very inclined
toward wishful thinking,
and that's a
designer's worst enemy.
[LAUGHTER]
Learning about yourself,
as I mentioned,
having a creative self-image
is very, very important.
You have to be able
to rely on that.
You learn lots of other
things, and that list
could go on and on.
You learn about other people.
You learn about how to
deal with other folks.
This thing that I mentioned
about the bonding that
happens when a team
works together,
and how you have
to learn to give up
part of the project and trust
somebody else to do it--
the process of sharing.
So another part of this thing
is learning about society--
the deal that's made when
you become a professional.
You get to stand
on the shoulders
of the giants in exchange
for an obligation
to do the right thing
when you're up there
and can see a long way.
Students designing this
scooter for instance,
had to think really hard about
the safety implications of it,
and I think they did a
very responsible job.
They made sure that the
brakes were really quite good.
The students that designed
that battery-operated water
scooter for kids went through
a lot of experiments and stuff
about the length of kids' hair
and how far back the propeller
head to be from the
grid to keep air
from getting trapped in there
so that no one could get
held under water by it.
When the projects
become real, the ethics
become much more obvious
and an integral part
of what they're doing.
Now, another cut on
this is Gardner's.
I think he's up to
eight or so now.
I think eight's probably
a pretty big number,
but I do think it's very clear
that there are different kinds
of intelligence.
Someone once summarized the
multiple intelligence thing
in this way, and I think that
that's probably pretty close.
We need some of all of
those, but various of us
are stronger in various suits.
And I think if you
look at that, there
are some skills and tools--
CAE, CAD, et cetera--
that can help you
in things smart,
but judgment is probably
what it's really about.
If you look at the
people smart thing,
there are some planning
tools and computer aids
and lots to learn
from the Sloan School,
but leadership is probably
what it's really all about.
And if you look at
situation smart,
there are a lot of ways to apply
logic and think very carefully,
but wisdom is probably what
you're really talking about.
And again, I think Einstein
was right when he said,
wisdom is knowing
what's important.
So we try to get students
involved in bumping
into all of those things.
Now, it ain't easy.
There is some trouble.
Things are not as simple
as they might seem.
I have a doctoral
student named Ben Linder.
He's a great student.
He's doing a thesis on
estimation, a doctoral thesis.
Because of his thesis,
we have gathered data
from seniors in
Mechanical Engineering
from six of the 12 most
highly-rated schools
of engineering in the country.
I'm just going to focus
on one part of that data.
We asked them to
take five minutes
to estimate the energy content
of a 9-volt transistor battery,
one of these things,
one of these things
that we all know very well.
The data-- we have
lots of data, so it's
statistically significant data.
It's here.
I don't expect you to see
that, but the sad thing
is there's only data from
about 80% of the students
because 20% of them used
the wrong units for energy.
Now another cut on
this is Gardner's.
I think he's up to
eight or so now.
I think eight's probably
a pretty big number,
but I do think it's very clear
that there are different kinds
of intelligence.
Someone once summarized the
multiple intelligence thing
in this way, and I think that
that's probably pretty close.
We need some of all of
those, but various of us
are stronger in various suits.
And I think, if
you look at that,
there are some
skills and tools--
CAE, CAD, et cetera--
that can help you
in things smart,
but judgment is probably
what it's really about.
If you look at the
people smart thing,
there are some planning
tools and computer aids
and lots to learn
from the Sloan School,
but leadership is probably
what it's really all about.
And if you look at
situation smart,
there are a lot of ways to apply
logic and think very carefully,
but wisdom is probably what
you're really talking about.
And again, I think Einstein
was right when he said,
wisdom is knowing
what's important.
So we try to get students
involved in bumping
into all of those things.
Now, it ain't easy.
There is some trouble.
Things are not as simple
as they might seem.
I have a doctoral
student named Ben Linder.
He's a great student.
He's doing a thesis on
estimation, a doctoral thesis.
Because of his thesis,
we have gathered data
from seniors in
Mechanical Engineering
from six of the 12 most
highly-rated schools
of engineering in the country.
I'm just going to focus
on one part of that data.
We asked them to
take five minutes
to estimate the energy content
of a 9-volt transistor battery,
one of these things,
one of these things
that we all know very well.
The data-- we have
lots of data, so it's
statistically significant data.
It's here.
I don't expect you to see
that, but the sad thing
is there's only data from
about 80% of the students
because 20% of them used
the wrong units for energy.
So we couldn't plot that.
The scatter in the data is
merely a billion to one.
So somehow, we've missed making
the numbers mean anything.
The students don't know whether
a 9-volt transistor battery
could make a butterfly's
wing flap once or carry
an automobile all the way
across the United States
or is equivalent to a
thermonuclear device.
A billion is a big
number, and we're
giving these folks incredibly
powerful tools to work with.
And in order for them to do
the ethically proper thing,
we have to make sure
that they understand.
Here's another kind
of spooky book.
I left the image of the tattered
book because it is kind of old.
It's about 1960 or
something like that.
This guy named Perry was with
a working group at Harvard.
Probably a lot of you
know about the work.
He did some studies about
intellectual and ethical
development in the
college years, a scheme.
And my terrible
condensation of what he said
is that when you
arrive at college,
you live in a nice
black-and-white dual world,
and the professor always
knows what's right,
and homework problems are
either right or wrong.
And you go through some
real angst and struggle
because you find out the
boundaries are fuzzy,
and sometimes you don't
know what's important,
and it gets a little complex.
And then you come out
thinking, wow, I'm
really committed to
complex intellectual ideas,
and I can handle
complex thoughts.
Some folks may have
studied graduates
of technical institutes like
MIT and liberal arts colleges
some years ago and claimed that
the technical graduates come
out kind of in the
bottom of the bag,
and the liberal arts people come
out about halfway up the arrow.
I think that's--
I don't buy that.
I think that that
particular scheme doesn't
take into account some of the
very fundamental issues that it
should, but I think there
is a signal in that noise.
And I think we need to
pay attention to it.
In fact, I think we're
obligated to work really
hard to get better at using
hard fun and other things to get
across the complex nature
of the whole thing.
Now, another thing that
I think is very important
is pointed out by our
colleague Mike Dertouzos
in his new book What Will Be.
He talks about information
work, and there
are lots of authors
like Eli Noam
and the head of Xerox
Park in here in the paper
"Universities in the Digital
World," John Seely Brown.
A lot of smart people
are pointing out
that things are
changing in the world,
and they have a potential
big impact on the university,
and I think that's really true.
And I think we have
to be very careful
and make sure that we
make that an asset rather
than a liability.
But that's the subject
of another talk.
One of the things
that is very clear,
though, is that we
have to understand
what the core benefit
of a place like MIT is.
And I happen to
think that it has
to do with making
sure that we address
the really high-margin things.
Informed creative thinking
is, I think, where it is,
and I think lots of
people agree with that.
I think we get at that by giving
them the right mix of thinking,
doing, sharing, and our incoming
chairman of the faculty,
Lotte Bailyn, just heard
me say this the other day
and pointed out that I was
leaving out reflecting,
and I think she's
absolutely right
that that's a very important
part of the formula.
Now, what that means to me is
that being here for four years
or longer primarily derives
value from the community.
You're with a whole group of
people who are raising the bar,
helping you develop a new
self-image of yourself
so that you have
greater self-expectation
and the assumption that
you're going to do something
when you leave here.
Now, what that
means, I think, is
that Nerd Pride needs
to continue to blossom
and have some other
obvious dimensions.
Life is not a
homework assignment.
There's a lot more
to it than that.
And if you start looking, and
if we were really successful,
we would get students to think
about what my colleague Don
Schon argues in The
Reflective Practitioner--
that there isn't even a
right way to do things.
If you look at the reflective
practitioners in architecture
or medicine or
engineering, they all
do things in different ways, and
there's no right or wrong way.
And you need to understand and
develop your own philosophy
about how you're
going to do things.
In fact, if you go
even further out
and listen to
people like Capra--
the way of physics,
The Tao of Physics--
there is a great oneness.
Maybe it is that modern
physics and Eastern mysticism
are all the same.
I don't quite go
that far, but I think
this book makes some very
powerful points about how maybe
we shouldn't draw lines like
I did earlier in this talk
about learning, that separate
learning about yourself
from learning about others, from
learning about Mother Nature.
It's clear, though, that
these sorts of things
are really becoming much
more important and much more
integral to the
whole thing, and I
think it is absolutely clear,
also, that the new Cold
War is education.
There is nothing
more closely coupled
to either our standard of
living or our quality of life
than the success or failure
of our education system.
And I think we need a
Cold War on the same scale
as the last one.
Now, one of the
problems that we face
is this one, that
societies get the best
of what they celebrate.
That's really frustrating
to me in some sense.
A multi-billion dollar
engineering feat,
and it was named after a guy
who can hit a rock with a stick.
I like sports.
I do sports.
I participate in lots of sports.
But what were we doing?
Where were we celebrating
the evolutionary scale?
I understand that
Ted Williams was not
even nice to the
baseball fans in Boston.
There were literally thousands
of people in the Boston
area in the last
few decades who have
made really meaningful
contributions to society,
but we took this big
thing and did that.
So with that slide up,
I'd like to show you
a clip from coverage of last
year's FIRST, where you see
a young woman named Sarina Kay
making 19 seconds of comments,
and then I'll close.
KAY: Three years ago, if I
would've called my dad at 9:00
at night and said, Dad,
I'm at East Systems
working on the robot, he would
have been like, yeah, right.
Where are you?
He wouldn't believed me, and
at the beginning of this,
they didn't believe me.
I started realizing how
important these years are
for my later years--
that I need to work
hard now, and I
need to get my life on track
if I want to do anything.
- And that's the true
spirit of US FIRST.
KAY: I changed a lot more
than it appeared I did,
but I grew up a lot more.
And I think my parents
have realized that.
They trust me a lot more.
- Sarina Kay-- just one of
the many US FIRST stories
we've heard here today.
Now for the results of--
FLOWERS: OK, my closing slide
comes from my favorite poet,
the Sufi mystic poet Rumi.
And I think we at MIT and all
of you guys have to do this.
We have to make sure that we've
got the right big picture,
but we've got to get all
of our ducks in a row
while we're working that out.
And we've got some
immediate things.
We've got to have many
layers of horizons,
and we've got to get
them all in order.
Now, thank you very much.
I would like now to turn the
program over to Craig Ramsell,
and Boomwhacker's Rule
will become obvious.
[APPLAUSE]
RAMSELL: Hello, hello, hello.
I think most of you have no
clue what Boomwhackers are,
and I'm going to start by
telling you that neither do I,
bu I'm going to do
my best with them.
And I actually understand
that I'm out of time,
so I think what's
going to happen
is you're going to take
a Boomwhacker home.
Just kidding.
We're going to actually do
something with them here.
It sounds like some of you
are already doing something
with them here, but before
I get too far into that,
let me thank Beth Garvin
and Woodie Flowers
for having the vision to get
you all participating today.
And we're done
listening for a while,
and we're going to do
some participating.
I would also like
to say that when
we get everybody going in here,
it could get a little loud.
So maybe, if those
of you that have
any kind of hearing-assistive
devices going on
may need to take
them down a notch.
What else?
I would also like
to acknowledge a man
by the name of Arthur Hull,
who has been my biggest
customer, biggest fan, who
does these kinds of events
all the time for
corporate clients
as a team-building exercise.
What a gig.
I mean, what a gig.
He just flies around and
does this for people,
and they're having a good time.
Now, we have an
excellent assembly
of people who have rehearsed
all of about two minutes
with these.
And I promised Woodie that I
usually just completely wing
these things.
But this time we're
actually doing
a couple of rehearsed songs.
So we'll get into that.
The first thing I want you to do
when you get your tube in hand,
and it looks like they're
getting out there pretty fast.
Make sure you all have one--
preferably just one.
You'll be much
less confused-- not
that MIT grads can't handle it.
But we'll just
find out, won't we?
I do want to tell a
quick couple of anecdotes
while you're putting these out.
I stayed in the dorm
for the first time.
I was in Theta Delta Chi
fraternity when I was here,
and I stayed in a dorm
for the first time,
and there was this wonderful
communal bathroom experience.
And you go in, and you sit
on the toilet on one side,
and it's got this kind
of a seesaw effect.
And somebody sits
down on the other one,
and you think you're going to
launch out James Bond-style out
of your Aston Martin.
But so far, we're surviving.
Boomwhackers-- I've been asked
where did these come from,
and I usually respond
with well, where
do ideas come from, anyway?
And whatever you want to call
that source of intelligence
that we are all fortunate
enough to tap into now and then.
But there was a
literal inspiration,
and it was a cardboard tube
from a roll of gift wrap paper,
and I was living somewhere where
they were recycling cardboard,
but that had to be a
two by two foot square,
and this thing was three
feet long, and oh jeez,
it's going to be sticking
out, and these guys
are going to leave it
sitting on the curb
because I'm not
following directions.
I cut it in two, and
then the magic came.
I was not a drummer, still am
not a drummer, but I'm trying.
And I went do do do
do do, like this.
And I go, wow, that
sounds pretty good.
It's cardboard tubes, and
the tones are different.
I go, hmm.
One's longer than the other one.
I didn't cut it exactly in half.
I think this is like a
musical principle that's
been around for a while.
[LAUGHTER]
So I immediately beat
the tubes up to the point
where you can hardly hear them
do anything anymore and ran
across the street to
the neighbor and said,
I've got a great idea for
a new musical instrument.
Watch!
Do do do do do do.
And they go, oh, Craig.
I mean, you've been having
some health problems,
and we're really--
but we're really
worried about you.
Please don't just jump at the
first thing that comes to mind.
I ignored them.
I did, and now we
have Boomwhackers.
So you've been extremely,
extremely quiet with these.
The last time this
many were handed out,
you wouldn't have
been able to hear me.
So thank you for that.
The first thing I want you to
do is to tune your instrument.
Now you're laughing.
I know-- it only
produces one note.
But if they get a
little bit out of shape,
if they look at the
end, if it's oval,
you want to kind of smoosh it
down and make it round again.
And you're going to
find out that it becomes
much more sonorous that way.
[LOW ROAR OF BOOMWHACKERS]
And I will tell you
two more things.
One is I looked at
putting LEDs on here,
but it didn't pass the
cost-benefit analysis.
And they were
designed with Pod-POM.
Thank you, Steven.
All right.
OK, let it rip.
This is rumble,
or cutting loose.
I'll give you some signals.
This is taking the volume up.
This is bringing
the volume down.
Quieter, quieter.
Take it down.
Back up again, back up again.
We're going to go up again.
All right.
I'm going to give you a count
of four, and on one, keep going.
Keep going.
I'm going to give
you a count of four.
On one, everybody
is going to stop.
I'm going to go like that, OK?
You too.
Welcome.
OK.
One, two, three, four, boom!
Ah.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
Let's try that again.
Rumble.
[LOW ROAR OF BOOMWHACKERS]
One, two, three, four, boom!
Better.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
Let's do a song.
This-- and again, this is
where I would normally wing it.
But to accommodate Woodie here,
I've actually mapped this out.
And it might help with
the rehearsal, too.
OK, we're going to go.
I need my tubes.
Where are my tubes?
You guys got your tubes.
Let's get them out.
OK.
Thank you.
You want to come
up here and play?
I can use some help.
All right.
Now, here we go.
This is called Tech
Tool, and it goes like--
[TUBES STRIKING HEAD]
Now, I'm sorry.
Hang on.
Everybody has got your tone.
You do what I do.
If everything goes well,
these guys do what I do.
And then you can do what
they do because I'm going
to move on to something else.
So you follow your person
onstage, all right?
So here we go.
And you can hit the palm
of your hand if you want.
The head starts to
hurt after a while.
Thighs, back of the
chair in front of you,
as long as somebody
else isn't going to get
whacked when you do it.
All right.
Let's keep that going.
What am I doing?
I don't know what I'm doing, How
can we have an extra-short rim?
Have I got a purple?
OK.
The colors are musical tones.
They think you need
an explanation.
I'm giving you an explanation.
Long red is a C. Orange is a
D. Yellow is an E. Green, teal,
whatever--
G. Purple-- A. Little red--
octave on the C, high
C. Am I missing a tone?
I don't have my purple.
There's green.
I got two greens.
How bizarre.
No purple.
This is very strange.
Oh no, no.
I'm sorry.
Here it is.
OK, now we got it.
Thank you, Woodie.
You guys are doing great.
I think you got it down.
Let's leave you do.
All right, we're going
to do purple and orange.
This is so much easier when
you're not trying to plan it.
OK.
[MELODIC STRIKING OF TUBES]
Purple, orange, purple, orange.
Short red, yellow,
and short red.
Yellow, short red.
[MELODIC STRIKING OF TUBES]
Sounds good to me.
OK, this Is my secret weapon.
[MELODIC STRIKING OF TUBES]
OK, one more signal here.
This is going to be
the speed it up signal.
So we're going to do like this.
[MELODIC STRIKING OF TUBES]
OK, take it up.
Take it up.
If you haven't destroyed
your hands yet.
All right, take them down.
All right.
Bring them down.
Back up.
[MELODIC STRIKING OF TUBES]
One, two, three, four, boom!
Hey!
[CHEERING]
Congratulations.
We'll do one more
quick thing here.
I want to just get a sound
of just the individual tones.
So let's start from the
long one here, the red,
and work our way up.
Red.
Let's hear a long red.
OK.
Orange.
Orange up, red down, red out.
Orange down, yellow up.
Yellow down, green up.
Green down, purple up.
Purple down, short red up.
There you have it.
Pentatonic scale, major
pentatonic scale, key of C.
[APPLAUSE]
FLOWERS: Thank you.
All right.
RAMSELL: Let me-- there's
a couple closing things.
There was just a
couple of things.
I'm not sure what you
were instructed to say,
as opposed to me.
So what I'd like to do
is say, my understanding
is you're welcome
take your tubes home.
And if you decide
you'd rather not,
there is going to be
a place where they're
collected, correct, Beth?
Out here somewhere,
and they'll get off
to someone deserving, which
is not me, by the way.
And we do have a limited number
of sets for sale at the expo.
It will take us a little
while to get over there,
but it's probably roughly
between one and three
that will be there.
And please come by
and see us, even
if you don't want to buy some,
just to have a little more fun.
All right.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Thank you, Woodie.
FLOWERS: Fantastic.
The Technology Day
luncheon is now
in the Johnson Athletic Center.
All afternoon, there is a
terrific expo in Sala de Puerto
Rico, and starting
from 3:00 to 5:00
are the panels, so get out there
and enjoy the rest of the day.
Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]